Und damit herzlich willkommen zum Chaos Radio in Blumen, Folge 205, das Chaos Radio, die Sendung, wo der Chaos Computer Club und Leute aus seinem Umfeld das Studium übernehmen und uns über ein Thema unterrichten, erleuchten oder erzählen, das irgendwie meistens mit diesem digitalen Kram zu tun hat, der da draußen rumschwebt und der mittlerweile unser aller Leben bestimmt Computer, Internet und dieses ganze Zeug, das sich niemals durchsetzen wird. Und heute ist eine dieser Sendungen, wo wir mal ein bisschen zurück gucken, weil das mit den Computern und den Smartphones und diesen ganzen Dingen, die ganz viel rechnen und online sind, das ist ja nicht erst seit gestern so. Das geht schon eine ganze Weile so. Deswegen beschäftigen wir uns heute mit etwas, das man eigentlich aus Hipster-Kreisen kennt. Also es gibt ja dieses, jemand kommt mit einer ganz alten Leder-Tasche an und zeigt sie stolz her und du fragst, was ist das? Ist das nachgemacht? Und er so, nein, das ist Vintage. Und das hat ja diesen Klang etwas ganz Besonderes zu sein. Und das gibt es tatsächlich auch. Dieses Alt, aber funktioniert immer noch und macht das, was es soll im Computerbereich. Vintage Computing heißt das demzufolge ganz richtig und damit wollen wir uns heute ausführlich beschäftigen. Auch ihr seid heute eingeladen anzurufen, wenn ihr wollt, unter 0331 70 97 110 und von eurem ersten Vintage Computing-Erlebnis zu erzählen. Also der Computer, den ihr zum ersten Mal in der Hand hattet, mit dem ihr zum ersten Mal was zu tun hattet. Vintage Computing hört sich jetzt aber auch so ein bisschen an, wie alte weißhaarige Männer sitzen um einen Tisch, streichen sich bedächtig durch den Badensaal. Ja, damals, als noch alles aus einem Stück gefeilt war und die Computer noch mit Dampf funktionierten, damals. Aber so ist es gar nicht. Ich möchte euch die Leute vorstellen, die heute hierher gekommen sind, um über Vintage Computing mit uns zu reden. Das ist zuallererst der Herr Dani Mohallon. Guten Tag.
Schönen guten Abend.
Nur mal so jetzt für unsere Privatstatistik. Wie alt bist du?
32.
Okay, das ist ja noch nicht ganz tot, im einen.
Ich lebe noch, ja.
Du interessierst dich für Vintage Computing, machst es aber nicht selber.
Genau.
Okay, wie bist du dazu gekommen? Oder warum findet man sowas interessant?
Na, weil es selten ist. Also warum interessierst du dich für einen Oldtimer? Warum schraubst du Ewigkeiten in deiner Garage irgendwie an irgendwie einen uralten Autostrom, für den du nur noch ganz schwer Ersatzteile bekommst?
Ich mache sowas nicht, aber ich verstehe, was du willst. Sehr gut. Dann haben wir Dexter. Hallo Dexter. Darf man auch von dir erfahren, wie alt du bist?
Ich bin 32.
Und was tust du, wenn du nicht Vintage computest oder im Radio über Vintage Computing redest?
Na ja, also ich habe auch noch andere Hobbys. Ich zeichne eigentlich ganz gerne und werke auch gerne mit Holz. Das ist auch immer ganz hilfreich, wenn man mal sich was nachbauen will, was so ein bisschen auf Vintage getrimmt ist. Ja, na gut, ich habe natürlich auch einen Job in der IT und poah, mir auch gerne.
Also es sind Menschen wie du und ich, möchte man sagen, die sich für Vintage Computing interessieren. Und dann haben wir noch Zeltophil. Hallo und guten Abend.
Wie alt bist du? Ich bin 25.
Und machst was?
Vintage Computing.
Ja, okay, möglicherweise hat das damit zu tun, dass du in dieser Realsendung bist, aber was machst du denn, soll ich jetzt sagen, in deinem normalen Leben?
Ansonsten bin ich auch so ein Nerd, studiere auch Informatik, ja.
Okay, und wie bist du zum Vintage Computing gekommen? Oder halt! Bevor wir das machen, was zur Hölle, also was ganz genau, ist denn eigentlich Vintage Computing? Ich stelle mir jetzt tatsächlich sozusagen so alt wie möglich mit Spinnenweben und möglicherweise noch Zahnrädern zum Dranrennen, oder was versteht ihr unter Vintage Computing?
Also da gibt es immer so Diskussionen drüber, was ist denn jetzt schon Vintage, was nicht. Und zum Beispiel beim Vintage Computing Festival Europe in München, was es schon seit 14, 15 Jahren gibt, wird immer gesagt, es muss hauptsächlich spannend sein. Es muss jetzt nicht unbedingt super alt sein. Es gibt immer die Regel, alles, was jünger als 10 Jahre ist, auf jeden Fall nicht. Aber irgendwie so ein alter Pension-PC ist jetzt auch vielleicht schon älter als 10 Jahre, aber es ist trotzdem langweilig, das wäre jetzt auch kein Vintage.
Aber generell ist Vintage schon erstmal nur einfach alt?
Alt und interessant.
Alt und interessant, okay.
Also es lässt sich leichter sagen, was es nicht ist, als was es ist.
Na gut, da können wir vielleicht noch genauer zu kommen. Dexter, kannst du ganz kurz versuchen zusammenzufassen, was Vintage Computing für dich ist? Oder ist es auch alt und interessant?
Naja, das ist schon richtig, es muss irgendwie spannende Hardware sein. Also gerade bei diesem Vintage-Zeug hat man ja immer meistens ein Stück Hardware vor sich, was nicht so alltäglich ist, also was man auch nicht mehr so leicht bekommt. Und wo einem dann im Grunde dann auch klar ist, dass es da vielleicht noch 10 Stück von gibt. Und mir macht es halt immer Freude, sowas dann halt zu pflegen, zu restaurieren, wieder ans Funktionieren zu bringen. Und das ist aber auch so ein bisschen wie eine Art Schnitzeljagd, weil man muss dann halt auch an verschiedenen Stellen Information, also Dokumentation und Software zusammensuchen. Also oft ist, wenn das bei einem dann ankommt, das funktioniert dann meistens gar nicht. Man muss da erstmal ein bisschen Arbeit reinstecken.
Okay, also sagen, das sind alte Dinge, die man wieder aufbauen kann. Es hört sich auch ein bisschen an, als ob das Aufbauen wichtiger ist, als dass es dann nachher funktioniert.
Das ist eine Sache, die mir sehr Spaß macht, das wieder zu restaurieren. Also bei dem Vintage Computing kann man auch ziemlich gut Parallelen ziehen. Also wie auch schon richtig gesagt wurde, den Oldtimern oder diese Vintage-Fernseher-Radio-Bassler-Szene, das ist ja im Grunde auch so ein Ding, was dazu irgendwie passt. Deswegen mache ich das auch immer ganz gerne. Aber einen Oldtimer habe ich nicht.
Wie bist du denn dazu gekommen? Also was war denn dein erstes Vintage-Erlebnis?
Na ja, es hat halt damit angefangen. Also ich muss dazu sagen, ich bin eigentlich jetzt nicht so die klassische Generation C64. Also wir hatten damals ein Windows PC, so ein Windows 95 mit Pentium 90 MHz. Und ich habe mir dann immer die Frage gestellt, was war denn jetzt vorher da? Also ich habe versucht, den herauszufinden, wie die Computer davor funktioniert haben. Also dann habe ich mich halt für DOS interessiert und mir auch da einen Computer für besorgt. Und da habe ich mich halt gefragt, was war vor DOS da, was gab es noch? Und dann habe ich auch mal einen C64 entdeckt und auch die ersten Macintoshes. Und ja, eigentlich war es halt immer die Frage, wie funktioniert das? Und wie ist man zu dem Entwicklungsstand gekommen, den man eigentlich jetzt gerade vor sich hat?
Und das sozusagen, also die Reise in die Vergangenheit lief dann sozusagen sehr schnell, hörte sich das ja an. Also die Dinge, die man noch kennt, die man vielleicht noch mal gehört hat. Und ist dann bist du irgendwie angekommen bei dem, was richtig alt ist.
Ja genau, man will immer irgendwie was Älteres haben. Aber es ist schon richtig, es ist schon irgendwie so eine Art Zeitreise. Ich stelle mir das auch mal ein bisschen so wie eine Zeitreise bildhaft vor, weil man reist halt in die Vergangenheit mit dieser Zeitmaschine, diesem alten Computer, wenn man so will.
Okay, zählt du viel. Wie war das bei dir? Wie bist du auf Vintage gekommen?
Ich habe erst der späten eigenen Rechner gehabt und habe aber von einem Menschen von meinem Chaos-Treff eine alte HP Workstation bekommen. Die habe ich dann nach Hause geschleppt, war mega schwer. Zu der Zeit fuhr auch kein Bus mehr und ich hatte keinen Monitor. Dann habe ich bei uns aus der Schülervertretung noch einen alten Röhrenmonitor nach Hause geschleppt. Dann wollte ich ein Netzwerk haben. Meine Eltern haben gesagt, ich darf kein Kabel in mein Zimmer legen. Dann musste ich mir erklären lassen, wie ich über mein Notebook, was ich ein paar Wochen später bekommen habe, WLAN dahin bridgee. So habe ich angefangen, mich mehr mit solchen Systemen zu beschäftigen.
Ist das noch etwas, was man heute als Computer kennen würde? Oder war das schon noch eher schrankmäßig?
Nö. Im Prinzip ein Tower, den man unterm Schreibtisch stehen hat.
Also noch ein normaler Computer, aber schon ein bisschen aus der Mode gekommen.
Einfach das, was man nicht als normaler Anwender bei sich zu Hause stehen hat, aber was man vielleicht auf Arbeit herum stehen hätte.
Und diese Bastelarbeit hat dich dann dazu geführt, dann noch weiter zurückzugehen?
Ja, erst habe ich halt irgendwie so genommen, was ich kriegen konnte, als ich angefangen habe. Und dann habe ich festgestellt, dass ich mich halt für bestimmte Systeme interessiere. Also im Fall von Computern wären das halt Workstations, so meistens aus den 90er Jahren, wo verschiedene Unixe drauflaufen, dass man sich die unterschiedlichen Unix-Varianten angucken kann, also das Betriebssystem.
Was ist denn der Unterschied zwischen einer Workstation und einem Desktop-Rechner?
Also heutzutage gibt es die Klasse Workstation eigentlich kaum noch. Das wäre einfach ein Desktop-PC mit mehr Leistung.
Hatte der früher irgendwelche besonderen Aufgaben? Oder nannte man das so, weil es stand halt bei den Leuten, die viel Geld hatten und arbeiten mussten. Deswegen war es eine Workstation.
Na, es ist so ein Zwischending zwischen einem Desktop-Rechner und einem Server. Und es gibt zum Beispiel speziell welche für Grafik, also was auch eingesetzt wurde in der Filmindustrie. Aber es steht halt nicht irgendwo in einem Rechenzentrum weit weg, sondern die Leute haben es wirklich bei sich unterm Tisch und können direkt daran arbeiten. Aber es hat mehr Leistung.
Dieses Vintage Computing, das machst du ja nicht nur zu Hause in deinem Zimmer mit der HP Workstation, sondern du bist bei der, die oder das Afra?
Die Afra, die Abteilung für Redundanz Abteilung.
Ah ja, was ist das genau?
Das ist ein neuer Hacker Space in Berlin, gibt es seit Ende 2012. Und da machen wir auch einiges mit Vintage Computing. Wobei das Computing da sehr weit gefasst ist. Zum Beispiel gibt es den Vintage Computing Abend jeden Donnerstag.
Das ist ja quasi heute.
Ja, aber ich bin nicht da. Da haben wir zum Beispiel ein paar Homecomputer rumstehen, mit denen man spielen kann. Und wir haben eine PDPL 34A, die wir wieder restaurieren wollen. Und manchmal bringen Leute kleine Spielekonsolen mit. Und ein Mensch frickelt gerade an einem ganz alten, portablen Computer rum. Lauter so Sachen. Worauf wir halt gerade Lust haben.
Da treffen Sie sozusagen Bastler, die einfach an alten Computern herumschrauben. Kann man da als jemand, der jetzt denkt, würde ich mir mal angucken, aber ich habe eigentlich keine Ahnung, darf man einfach vorbeikommen und mal gucken?
Ja, sowieso. Also in der Afra kann man immer vorbeikommen und auch zum Vintage Abend. Manchmal gibt es sogar auch ein bisschen mehr Programme. Einmal hat zum Beispiel mein Vater einen alten Macintosh vorgestellt und hat gezeigt, wie er damals in Hypercard für mich eine, im Prinzip Lego-Eisenbahnverwaltung geschrieben hat, wo man sich die Schienen zusammenklicken konnte. Und so, da kann man sich natürlich einfach hinsetzen und zuhören.
Okay, jetzt habt ihr das nicht nur sozusagen in dieser Afra gemacht, sondern es gibt auch jetzt einen Vintage Computing Festival Berlin heißt das, glaube ich. Ja. Was passiert da? Warum macht man sowas überhaupt?
Damit man auch mal von anderen Leuten die alten Computer zu sehen kriegt. Also es gibt ja Sachen, die sind sehr selten, die hat man nicht, da kommt man nicht ran. Und manche Leute haben sowas und manche Leute haben selber tolle Sachen gefrickelt, die man sich da angucken kann. Ja. Das Vintage Computing Festival Berlin, das findet statt vom 3. bis 5. Oktober, wobei am 3. nur Aufbau der Aussteller ist. Und am 4. und 5. Oktober gibt es unter anderem Vorträge und Workshops zu rund um alte Computer und was man mit Computern machen kann. Und es gibt mehrere Ausstellungen. Es gibt ganz viele kleine Ausstellungen von diversen Hobbyisten. Es sind auch ein paar Museen vertreten, wie zum Beispiel das Deutsche Technikmuseum aus Berlin und das Heinz-Nixdorf-Forum, ich glaube das größte Computermuseum in, ich glaube, sogar ganz Europa. Und es gibt einen Raum mit ausschließlich Apple-Technik. Und wir haben auch einen Raum für hauptsächlich Kinder zum Spielen, aber im Prinzip für alle offen zum Spielen mit Home-Computern, Spielekonsolen, sogar Arcade-Automaten. Ja, und ganz viel auch zum Selbermachen.
Okay, das kann man sich ja alles angucken. Jetzt sieht man schon, es gibt anscheinend sozusagen auch im Vintage-Bereich, das ist nicht einfach nur Vintage und Alt und es gibt auch verschiedene Unterteilungen. Was kann man denn so sagen, in welchen Bereichen es beim Vintage gibt?
Ja, ich kann ja mal was dazu sagen. Also das ist recht breit gefächert eigentlich. Zum einen sind da die, schon mal angesprochen, Arcade-Automaten. Das ist eigentlich eine völlig eigene Szene. Dann gibt es die Leute, die an Spielekonsolen rum basteln und die Retro-Spiele spielen. Dann gibt es Leute, die interessieren sich für Großrechner, also für Sachen, die so im Businessbereich eingesetzt worden sind. Dann gibt es eine Home-Computer-Szene und das muss man auch nochmal in Ost und West unterteilen. Da gibt es recht viel. Dann gibt es auch noch Leute, die bauen Sachen nach, sei es mit Emulatoren oder mit sogenannten FPGA-Chips. Da kann man nämlich auch Logik mit nachbauen. Das wird auch dort bei diesen Vintage Computing Sachen eingesetzt.
Das sind sozusagen die vier großen Felder, könnte man sagen?
Ja, also würde ich auch so sehen. In meinem Fall ist es so, dass ich mich eher für Homecomputer interessiere. Hauptsächlich Z80.
Ein Z80?
Z80, ja. Das ist eine Mikroprozessor-Architektur gewesen, die in den 80ern populär war. Zum Beispiel, wenn man einen Homecomputer, der vielleicht halbwegs bekannt ist, dazu nennen könnte, das wäre Schneider CPC zum Beispiel. Vielleicht kennen das einige noch. Hauptsächlich lief auf diesem Computer ein Betriebssystem, das hieß CPM. Das steht für Kontrollprogramm für Mikrocomputer. Das ist von der Firma Digital Research entwickelt worden. Das war das erste Mal so ein Betriebssystem, das so ein bisschen wie DOS auf jedem Rechner lief. Die Rechner waren damals bei beiden nicht gleich. Da hatte man dann einen Rechner, hatte da ein bisschen Software drauf. Wenn man dann mal Daten austauschen wollte, dann war das ein Riesenproblem, weil der nächste Rechner konnte die Diskette-Formate nicht, hatte vielleicht einen anderen Prozessor, einen anderen Zeichensatz. Das ging alles gar nicht. Bei CPM hat man versucht, es erstmal so ein bisschen in Normierung zu machen. Was nicht heißt, dass irgendwie eine Boot-Diskette, die auf dem einen Rechner erstellt wurde, auf dem nächsten Rechner bootet oder dass die Disketten überhaupt passen. Aber das Betriebssystem war so ein bisschen gleich. Man konnte auch die gleiche Software auf verschiedenen Computern ausführen.
Du hast gesagt, du interessiert dich besonders dafür. Was ist das Besondere an diesem einen Ding jetzt?
Das hat mir immer ziemlich gefallen. Ich muss ganz ehrlich zugeben, ich gucke auch bei so Computern erstmal ein bisschen auf Design. Wie sehen die aus? Wie sind die designt? Und bei den CPM-Computern waren es immer die schönsten Designs. Ich mag hauptsächlich Computer, die die Bildschirm- und Tastatur in einem Gehäuse vereinen. CPM-Computer waren eigentlich nicht so richtig die Consumer-Computer, sondern das waren eher Computer aus dem professionellen Bereich, von C128 oder Schneider CPC abgesehen. Aber eigentlich waren das eher Computer für den Profibereich. Die hatten auch wenig Grafikfähigkeiten, also irgendwie 80 Zeichen, 25 Zeilen, das war es schon.
Was genau machst du damit? Wo kriegst du so ein Ding erst mal her?
Na ja, also man kann das in diversen Online-Auktionshäusern natürlich erwerben. Da ist das dann manchmal teuer. Aber manchmal bekommt man das auch geschenkt, wenn man Glück hat. Also ich kriege das manchmal geschenkt von Leuten, die irgendwie sowas irgendwo finden und mir dann zustecken.
Und was laufen die dann? Wenn sie nicht laufen, würfst du sie weg und suchst einen Ganzen? Oder baut man sich aus verschiedenen Computern einen zusammen? Oder regulierst du jedes Schräubchen einzeln und fallen?
Na ja, da gibt es zwei verschiedene Methoden. Also wegschmeißen tue ich sie natürlich nicht. Also man kann die eigentlich relativ gut reparieren, weil die sind nicht besonders komplex. Da ist halt dieser Z80 drin. Das ist so ein relativ Standard-CPU. Wenn man jetzt nicht groß Pech hat und dass irgendwelche Chips kaputtgehen, die man jetzt nicht mehr kriegt, also da müsste man schon echt viel Pech für haben. Aber na ja, in den meisten Fällen sind es Kleinigkeiten. Man kriegt es wieder hin. Ansonsten, ich meine, wenn es jetzt irgendwie total schaden ist, also ich habe auch ein Terminal, das ist jetzt kein Computer, das ist halt nur so ein Terminal, so eine Anzeigeeinheit mit einer Tastatur im Grunde. Da habe ich eine rumliegen, die ist innen komplett verrostet. Das ist kompletter Totalschaden. Das kann man eigentlich nur noch alles, was drin ist, rausnehmen, was anderes reinmachen. Aber ich sage mal so, wenn da was geht, dann versuche ich auch die Hardware zu retten.
Was machst du dann, wenn die Dinger wieder laufen? Ist dann sozusagen der Prozess, der für dich spannend ist, abgeschlossen?
Naja, also ich sage mal so, wenn die wieder laufen, dann, ja, da musst du dich halt was Neues ausdenken. Aber da findet man eigentlich immer schon was. Ich meine, es ist halt ein Computer und dann kann man ja vielleicht irgendwie mal gucken, ob man irgendwie ein Spiel dafür findet oder ob man vielleicht selber ein Programm dafür schreibt. Ja, aber dass wir das wieder ans Laufen kriegen, ist für mich natürlich schon der spannendste Prozess.
Zeltophil, wie ist es bei dir? Hast du auch sozusagen ein Lieblingsding in dieser ganzen Vintage Computing-Ära?
Ja, es gibt verschiedene. An Computern sammle ich halt so 90er-Jahre Workstations, wie eben schon gesagt. Aber ich interessiere mich auch sehr für programmierbare Taschenrechner und insbesondere Taschenrechner mit umgekehrter polnischer Notation. Also eine Postfix-Notation, sodass man zum Beispiel 1 plus 2 nicht eingeben würde, sondern 1, dann schiebt man die 1 auf den Stapel, dann gibt man die 2 ein, dann die Operation, die man ausführen will, also zum Beispiel plus, und dann drückt man Enter. Und dann wird das Ganze ausgeführt.
Das ist aber schon eher so eine Art Sammlerleidenschaft, oder gibt es da auch irgendwas zu restaurieren?
Doch, klar. Also ganz oft sind die Tastaturen nicht mehr in Ordnung. Da muss man die Kontakte säubern und so. Und oft sind auch irgendwelche Kontakte abgebrochen von irgendwas, weil die Teile irgendwo in die Ecke geschmissen wurden. Da muss man auch ein bisschen reparieren. Aber oft ist es nur einfach das Gerät säubern und dann läuft es wieder. Manchmal sind die Displays kaputt, solche Sachen.
Und wo kriegst du die Teile her?
Taschenrechner kriege ich eher selten geschenkt. Dafür gebe ich schon manchmal Geld aus. Aber auch so Workstations, die fallen aus der Uni raus, was halt nicht mehr gebraucht wird. Jetzt gerade will niemand mehr Sun haben. Überall kommen Sun-Rechner her. Und Leute wissen inzwischen, dass ich den Graben sammle. Und fragen mich halt, bevor sie es wegschmeißen.
Hast du dann eine eigene kleine Garage, wo das alles untergebracht wird?
Leider nicht. Ich habe eine Wohnung, wo ein paar Computer mit mir drin sind.
Hust, hust. Gibt es eigentlich außer der Sammelleidenschaft, also außer diesem, so denke ich, interessiere mich für dieses alte Ding, gibt es da noch andere Gründe, warum man solche Maschinen am Laufen halten sollte? Bei Computerspielen kann ich es mir vorstellen. Es gibt für manche Leute den Nostalgie-Faktor. Dann wollen die diese Dinge auf dem möglichst Original sehen. Aber bei diesen ganzen Maschinen, die ihr sammelt, gibt es da einen rationalen Grund, das zu machen? Oder ist das wirklich nur museale Sammelleidenschaft?
Es gibt auch da die Nostalgie. Viele Menschen wollen noch mal den ersten Computer, auf dem sie programmiert haben oder den sie in der Schule benutzt haben, noch mal benutzen. Aber andererseits ist es auch immer schade, Hardware wegzuwerfen, die noch läuft, die man noch einsetzen könnte. Aber da hat man auch immer wieder das Problem, dass sie mehr Strom frisst als aktuelle Hardware.
Aber so richtig praktikabel ist das doch nicht, oder? Also die Hardware einzusetzen, egal, Strom hin oder her.
Es kommt halt immer so ein bisschen drauf an, was für Hardware du restaurierst. Also wenn du Hardware restaurierst, die lange im Einsatz war und auch in wichtigen Gebieten im Einsatz war. Wobei wichtig sich sowohl im monetären Sinne, als auch im emotionalen Sinne. Also wenn du jetzt beispielsweise viele Leute hast, die einen gewissen Homecomputer hatten und dort irgendwie, denen dann irgendwann einfällt, ach, ich hatte ja noch diesen Diskettenstapel. Und wenn du jetzt einen aktuellen Rechner hast, dann versuchen wir diesen Diskettenstapel irgendwie sinnvoll einzulesen. Von den einzelnen Formaten, in denen die Dokumente oder was auch immer dort drauf gespeichert sind, mal ganz abgesehen. Und jetzt kannst du natürlich dann sie an einen der vielen verschiedenen Emulatoren bauen. Falls es für deinen Mac irgendwie noch so ein USB-Dingsy gibt, wo du dann irgendwie noch diese alten Disketten auslesen kannst. Die andere Möglichkeit ist natürlich, dass du bei irgendjemandem vorbeigehst, der so einen alten Rechner hat. Und auf dem Wege dann versuchst du, über diese Hardware deine Daten ins 21. Jahrhundert zu retten.
Okay, das sagen Menschen lieber. Kommen solche Fragen auch zu euch?
Das gibt es öfter auf Mailinglisten so. Hallo, ich habe hier noch diese 5, 1, 25 Zoll Floppy, ich weiß nicht mehr von was für einem System sie kamen, aber da sind ganz wichtige Daten drauf, die ich unbedingt haben muss und möglichst bald.
Der Indiana Jones des Computers, könnte man sagen. Wie sind die Erfolgschancen, wenn man sich da auch nicht wendet und sagt, kannst du mal bitte gucken?
Kommt drauf an, in was für einem Zustand das Medium ist. Also wenn da schon die ganze Beschichtung runterbröckelt, dann ist da nicht mehr viel zu machen. Dann kann man es einmal lesen und dann war es das. Aber sonst, wenn man die Hardware findet, mit der man es auslesen kann, ist es eigentlich ganz gut. Es gab da auch vor kurzem eine Geschichte, dass alte Floppies vom Amiga, Atari? Von Andy Warhol gefunden wurden, wo noch Kunstwerke von ihm drauf waren. Und das hat dann auch so ein Computer Club wieder alles hergestellt.
Vintage Computing kann also alte Kunstwerke retten. Sehr spannend. Das ist eine kleine Einführung in die Welt des Vintage Computing. Wir hören jetzt eine kleine Musik, machen dann Nachrichten. Und danach geht es hier im Chaos Radio weiter. Ihr könnt auch, wie gesagt, gerne anrufen. 0331 77 97 110. Und von eurem ersten Computererlebnis erzählen. Das passt heute hier sehr gut. Denn wir reden ja ein bisschen über die Herkunft, die ersten Rechenmaschinen.
Hallo, ich bin Marion, die schwebende Jungfrau.
Aufgepasst.
Habt ihr gesehen?
Ähm, Marion, also wenn du so jungfraulich bist, wie du schwebst, dann äh... Au! Ist doch nicht so schlimm. Üb doch einfach noch ein bisschen. Also das Schweben.
Die Fritz-Nacht der Talente.
Auf der Bühne die unentdeckten Talente. Außerdem die Gewinner der letzten Nacht der Talente. Und ein geheimer Überraschungs-Ex, der so geheim ist, dass er selbst überrascht sein wird.
Samstag, 22. November. Im Großen Saal vom Admiralspalast Berlin.
Solang es noch keinen gibt, gibt es Karten überall, wo es Karten gibt. Die Fritz-Nacht der Talente.
Der iranische Präsident Rouhani hat dem Westen vorgeworfen, für das Erstarken des Terrorismus in der Welt verantwortlich zu sein. Vor der Vollversammlung der Vereinten Nationen sagte Rouhani, militärische Aggressionen gegen den Irak und Afghanistan und eine falsche Einschätzung der Entwicklungen in Syrien seien Beispiele für die verfehlte Strategie im Mittleren Osten. Terrorismus sei das Ergebnis von Armut, Unterentwicklung, Demütigung und Ungerechtigkeit. Rouhani hält außerdem ein internationales Abkommen über das Atomprogramm seines Landes bereits im November für möglich. Dafür müsse sich der Westen allerdings flexibel zeigen, sagte Rouhani. US-Präsident Obama hat die Ebola-Epidemie in Westafrika als Gefahr für die globale Sicherheit bezeichnet. Es handele sich um einen Gesundheitsnotfall, der eine internationale Antwort verlang, sagte Obama in New York. Unter der Leitung von UN-Generalsekretär Bahnen berieten hochrangige Vertreter über Hilfen für die betroffenen Staaten. EU-Kommissionspräsident Barroso kündigte an, die EU werde ihre Hilfen um weitere 30 Millionen auf insgesamt 180 Millionen Euro aufstocken. In Deutschland meldeten sich für die Hilfe in den westafrikanischen Ebola-Gebieten laut Verteidigungsministerin von der Leyen bereits etwa 4500 Freiwillige. Ein Fernsehteam ist bei einem Dreh zu einer Reportage im Görnitzer Park in Berlin-Kreuzberg attackiert worden. Das Kamerateam war am Donnerstagnachmittag in der Grünanlage an der Wiener Straße unterwegs. Bei Interviews wurde laut Polizei dann Unmut in einer Gruppe von bis zu zwölf Leuten laut. Ein junger Mann habe mit einem zugeklappten Taschenmesser hantiert und dann eine Flasche sowie zwei kleine Pflastersteine in Richtung des TV-Teams geworfen. Er habe einen Kameramann am Bein getroffen. Vor den alarmierten Polizisten flüchtete die Gruppe. Kurz darauf kehrte der Tatverdächtige zurück und wurde festgenommen. Bei der Lufthansa drohen wieder Streiks der Piloten. Die Gewerkschaft Cockpit hat heute die gerade erst wieder aufgenommenen Tarifgespräche mit der Lufthansa für gescheitert erklärt und Arbeitsniederlegungen angekündigt. Die Gewerkschaft kämpft dafür, dass die betriebsinterne Frührente für die Lufthansa-Piloten nicht abgeschafft wird. Auch die Verhandlungen zwischen der Deutschen Bahn und der Gewerkschaft Deutscher Lokmotivführer GDL sind erneut gescheitert. Ob es zu Streiks kommt, entscheiden die Gewerkschafter bis zum 2. Oktober in einer Urabstimmung. Die aktuellen Temperaturen in Berlin Köpenick 12 in Wannsee 14 Grad, Lindenberg meldet 12, Frankfurt, Falkensee und Wiesenburg melden 13 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es meist stark bewölkt und es kann hier und da noch etwas regnen. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 12 bis 10 Grad. Am Tag wird es dann wolkig und trüb mit gelegentlichem Regen bei maximal 16 bis 17 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin A100 Stadtring Richtung Wedding. Der Pritzer Tunnel ist wegen Wartungsarbeiten zwischen Buschkrugallee und Gratestraße bis 5 Uhr früh gesperrt. A115 A-Wurststadt auswärts zwischen Dreieckfunkturm und Hüttenweg ist die rechte Spur wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Tiergarten, die Straße des 17. Juni ist zwischen die Zagrabinstraße und Ebertstraße gesperrt wegen des Berlin-Marathons am Sonntag. Nach Brandenburg A12 Berlin Richtung Frankfurt-Oder zwischen Dreieck, Spreeau und Friedersdorf behindert ein kaputtes Fahrzeug im Baustellenbereich den Verkehr. Dort staut es sich. Letzter freier Ausfahrt ist Niederlehme. Sonst überall gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des Airbaby.
Und wenn ihr den Fritz Night Flight von Letzter nach verpasst habt oder ihn einfach nochmal hören wollt, dann hört ihn doch einfach nochmal, so oft ihr wollt und wann ihr wollt. Eine Woche lang im Musikstream auf fritz.de.
Heute Chaos Radio in Blumun mit Marcus Richter, Danimo Dexter und Zeltofil und es geht heute um Vintage Computing. Das heißt um die Computer, die Computer waren, bevor die Computer, Computer waren, die heute unsere Computer sind. Und dazu wollen wir natürlich auch eure Geschichten hören, was euer erster Computer war. Ihr könnt gerne anrufen.
0331 70 97 110.
Zum nächsten Mal. I'm fresh, you're prelly. Nein, das ist kein Kompliment, das ist eine Band mit dem Song Date hier im Chaos Radio im Blue Moon auf Fritz, wo ich nochmal herzlich willkommen heiße, Danimo. Hallo und guten Tag.
Schönen guten Tag.
Und es geht um Vintage Computing, das heißt alte Computer wieder zum Laufen bringen oder beziehungsweise mit alten Computern arbeiten und sie schön finden und angucken. Und wir haben schon festgestellt in der ersten halben Stunde, man macht das, weil es so anscheinend so ein grundsätzliches Interesse daran gibt, mal zu gucken, was früher so war. Und das geht tatsächlich nicht um die Computer, von denen man vielleicht mal gehört hat als altertümliche Monster, also Windows 95-Rechner oder Amiga oder C64, sondern es geht noch viel, viel weiter zurück. Dexter, du hast gerade schon erzählt, die Rechnungen, die du in der Hand hast, sind meistens dann noch Originalstücke, die du entweder kaufst für teures Geld oder geschenkt kriegst für wenig Geld. Ist das die einzige Möglichkeit, sozusagen an Retro-Computing heranzukommen oder geht das noch irgendwie anders?
Na ja, es gibt da Situationen, da will man einen Computer haben, aber es gibt halt keine Möglichkeit, da heranzukommen. Also eine Möglichkeit ist halt, man verwendet einen Emulator. Das ist ganz interessant, wenn man irgendwelche Software hat, die man da ausführen will und sich eigentlich für den Softwareteil mehr interessiert. Aber ich will ja als Sammler eigentlich...
Halt, bevor wir die Emulator so ungeliebt am Wegesrand liegen lassen, ist das eine einfache Sache? Also gibt es da auch dann irgendwie Webseiten, wo man hingehen kann und sagen kann, hier, gib mir mal bitte den alten... Was hast du vorhin gesagt? Z80?
Das ist ja richtig. Also in Emulator ist es heutzutage relativ leicht zu bekommen. Da gibt es mehrere Projekte. Also gerade, wenn man irgendwie so einen Computer hat wie der C64, da ist ein Emulator überhaupt kein Problem. Aber auch bei diesen PDP-Computern von Digital ist das überhaupt kein Problem. Da gibt es einen Emulator, der heißt SIM-H und es gibt noch andere. Und bei mir war das halt so, ich wollte halt eine PDP-8 haben. Und ich habe erst mal gedacht, okay, man könnte das mal versuchen mit einem FPGA.
Also FPGA taucht immer mal wieder auf, wenn man mit Leuten wie euch redet, sage ich jetzt mal so. Was ist das?
Also ein FPGA ist was ganz Tolles, also vor allem, wenn man mit alten Computern rum bastelt und überhaupt mit Elektronik was macht. Weil das ist nämlich im Grunde ein Chip, das kann man sich so vorstellen, der ab Werk halt noch formbar ist. Das heißt, man kann im Grunde sich so ein FPGA besorgen und dann im Grunde seinen eigenen Chip damit machen. Das ist ein relativ aufwändiger Prozess und man muss da auch von Elektronikdesign ein bisschen Ahnung haben, aber im Grunde hat man dann die Hardware tatsächlich vor sich. Es ist im Grunde ein richtig eigener Chip.
Das heißt, kann man sich das vorstellen und sagen, ein Computer in Rohform, also der noch nicht genau gesagt wurde, was für ein Computer sein soll?
Naja, eher ein Chip in Rohform. Also es ist halt so, dieser Chip ist natürlich, jeder Chip, der hat natürlich eine definierte Funktion, aber die Funktion dieses Chips ist eben halt gerade dadurch, dass man da drin halt kleine Logikelemente hat und zwar ganz viele, die programmierbar sind und die man selber verschalten kann und da kann man natürlich dann auch einen alten Computer draus bauen. So, jetzt war das bei mir halt mit dem FPGA so, dass ich halt damals eigentlich noch nicht so richtig wusste, wie ich das machen sollte. Ich habe dann erst mal angefangen, für die PDP-8 ein Panel zu bauen. Früher hatten die Computer so eine Konsole, nannte man das. Da waren halt kleine Lampen dran und Schalter und die Lampen haben im Grunde so die Register symbolisiert und den Adresszähler.
Okay, Dinge, die im Computer passieren.
Genau, im Grunde diese elementaren Zustände, die so ein Prozessor hat, die hat man da auf den Lampen gesehen und mit den Schaltern konnte man halt diese Zustände manipulieren, wenn man jetzt Fehler gesucht hat oder ein Programm starten wollte. Manchmal war es sogar so, da war in dem Computer, wenn man ihn angemacht hat, erst mal nichts drin. Er wusste auch gar nicht, wie man jetzt auf den Laufwerk zugreift und was macht. Da musste man erst mal so einen Urlader eintoggeln, hat man dazu gesagt. Da hat man an den Schaltern rumgeschaltet und da diesen Lader im Grunde weit für weit da in den Speicher eingegeben.
Also, lass mich jetzt noch mal zusammen, was man hat programmiert, in dem man Schalter umgelegt hat und man musste erst mal überhaupt die Funktionsfähigkeit des Computers programmieren.
Genau. Man ist halt hingegangen, im Handbuch hat man geguckt, okay, der und der Befehl, der hat jetzt die und die Bit-Kombination, hat man die an den Schaltern eingestellt und hat gesagt, hier schreiben. Dann hat er das in seine erste Speicherzelle geschrieben und den Adresszähler inkrementiert. Dann hat man den zweiten Befehl nachgeguckt und dann hat man so ein kleines Programm geschrieben. Und naja, in den meisten Fällen war das halt dieser Urloader, der dann halt von einem Lochstreifen das System nachgeladen hat oder ein Programm. Das ist so halt der Aufbau gewesen, die man auch bei der PDP-8 halt so hat. Die PDP-8, das war so ein klassischer...
Warte, warte, warte. Wir waren noch gerade bei Computer bauen.
Ich will das schon erzählen, aber wir mussten halt ein bisschen auch erzählen, um welchen Computer es da geht. Also war halt so ein Standard-Industrie-Rechner. Also ich hab halt dieses Panel gebaut, also ein Stück Blech genommen, die LEDs als Lampen rein gemacht. Dann hatte ich halt dieses Panel und dann hab ich es halt auch an den FPGA angeschlossen. Da hab ich halt gemerkt, das ist ganz schön schwer. Also es mit dem FPGA, das wird nix. Also so bin ich dann hingegangen und habe das Panel an einen handelsüblichen PC angeschlossen, mit einem Mikrocontroller dazwischen. Und dann habe ich einen Emulator genommen für die PDP8, also diesen Software-Emulator, und hab mir die Stellen rausgesucht, wo es im Grunde da drin um die CPU geht und wie man halt eben diese Registerzustände rauskriegt und wie man eben mit den Schaltern Dinge in das Programm reinkriegt. Dann habe ich das Panel sozusagen, also die Software so angepasst, dass die mit dieser Konsole halt geredet hat, da die Schalter abgefragt hat und auf den Lampen halt den Zustand ausgegeben hat und dass man dann halt diese Konsole nehmen konnte, als wäre sie der alte Computer und dann im Grunde das Gleiche machen konnte, an den Schaltern rumdrücken und da kleine Programme eingeben und laufen lassen. Dann haben da die Lampen geleuchtet und der Emulator hat im Hintergrund auf dem PC halt dann seine Arbeit verrichtet. Dann hatte ich noch einen Fernschreiber dran, der halt noch da als Textkonsole lief und dann war das im Grunde meine Interpretation einer PDP8.
Ist das, woher kenne ich denn sowas?
Das ist so ein bisschen wie lebenserhaltende Maßnahmen und man baut immer mehr dran und irgendwann kann man den Live-Support abschalten, wenn man quasi den Rest der Maschine auch noch nachbauen würde.
Der nächste Schritt wäre jetzt halt, diesen Emulator dann doch noch durch den FPGA zu ersetzen. Das könnte man machen, aber...
Oder sogar durch die Original-Schalte.
Was ich mich gerade frage, ich kenne das sozusagen, es gibt ja so Live-Rollenspiel, wo Leute so in Fantasy-Klamotten rumtun und so tun, als wären sie Ritter und Zauberer. Und dann gibt es Re-Enactment-Leute, die machen ganz originalgetreu das Mittelalter. Und das Klischee will, dass die einen auf die anderen so immer naserümpfend hingucken. Und ich frage mich gerade, ist das in der Vintage Computing-Szene auch so, dass sozusagen dann die Leute gibt, die haben eine originale PDP-8 rumstehen und die gucken dann so naserümpfend auf Leute, die das einfach nachbauen?
Auch da habe ich jetzt eher nicht so den Eindruck, also ich glaube, ich finde das eher schön und man kann sich halt austauschen darüber. Also nee, das da habe ich nicht den Eindruck, sowas habe ich nie erlebt.
Ach doch, ich schon. Also es gibt halt, wie du schon sagtest, die Leute, die sich mehr so für die Software interessieren, die nehmen dann halt den Emulator und benutzen ihre Software weiter. Und dann gibt es die Hardware-Leute, die sagen, nein, das geht doch nicht, das ist doch nicht dasselbe. Ich muss halt den Bootloader eintoggeln und so, das ist doch nicht dasselbe, sonst ich muss die Festplatte hören.
Das ist so ein bisschen der Unterschied zwischen den Leuten, die es einfach nur verstehen wollen und die Leute, die es halt haptisch mögen und die halt sagen, ach, die guten alten Zeiten, egal ob sie jetzt wirklich gut waren oder nicht.
Also ich kann von mir sagen, ich bin eigentlich jemand, der gerne das vor sich hat und auch gerne die Festplatte hört, aber trotzdem rieche ich nicht die Nase bei einem Emulator.
Gibt es dann auch schon sozusagen so, dass man einen kleinen Soundchip reinbaut in so ein Gehäuse, damit er so tut, als wäre er die Festplatte?
Ja, also es gibt ein Produkt, das ist sehr hilfreich, das nennt sich irgendwie HXC-Floppy-Emulator, das braucht man immer. Damit kann man halt ein Floppy-Laufwerk emulieren, das ist ein Stück hart. Wer das für den Computer aussieht wie ein Diskettenlaufwerk, kann man eine SD-Karte reinstecken und dann davon auch, also für den Computer sieht es aus wie eine Diskette dann.
Das macht aber keine Geräusche.
Doch, doch, die haben da einen kleinen Speaker drauf gemacht und das macht so ein bisschen diese Floppy-Geräusche nach. Ist ganz lustig, ja gut, also ich weiß, wie ich es machen werde, wenn bei mir gar kein Floppy-Laufwerk mehr geht, dann nehme ich nämlich ein kaputtes Floppy-Laufwerk, mache das daneben und mache diese vor und zurück Stepper-Signale, die leite ich dann noch durch, dann fährt wenigstens der Schreib- und Leseknopf noch hin und her und macht die Geräusche.
Aber du komponierst damit keine Musik.
Wie ist das eigentlich generell? Also ich frage mich ja, es gibt ja immer den Rechner und dann gibt es die Peripherie. Vielleicht gibt es sogar auch besondere Monitore oder sowas. Wie macht man das denn? Also ist es schwierig, die Schnittstellen irgendwie umzusetzen? Oder muss man das auch zusammenlöten von Hand?
Naja, also wir sagen ja, frickeln dazu. Wenn man sich da was bastelt, dann muss man auch unter Umständen mal Adapterkabel löten. Die Kabel sind ja auch manchmal dann auch einfach verloren gegangen. Besondere Monitore gibt es schon. Da gibt es zig Standards. Es gibt halt Leute, die Monitore über ganz normales TV-Signal kriegen. Gerade der C64 hat da so einen TV-Modulator drin, der erzeugt analoges Antennensignalen.
Und zwar in Europa anders als in Amerika, je nach Standard, PAL oder NTSC. Das hatte auch Auswirkungen auf die Geschwindigkeit des Prozessors, weil der entsprechend getaktet werden musste zum jeweiligen Ausgabegerät.
Das Problem tritt aber nur auf, wenn man jetzt rummodet und wenn man ein NTSC-Spiel auf PAL spielen will. Das ist so eher in der Konsolenwelt.
Wenn du das Ding für die Rechenpower haben willst, hättest du Vorteile, wenn du es auf NTSC umstellst, wenn du es nicht kriegst.
Ja, aber das ist so ein Konsolenproblem, glaube ich, eher.
Und halt C64.
Ja, also Video-Standards gibt es halt viele. Das ist ein bisschen ein Problem, wenn man moderne Monitore hat und die an einen alten Rechner anschließen will. Da gibt es aber auch mittlerweile Lösungen. Das kommt so ein bisschen aus der Spielautomaten-Szene. Da gibt es auch so ein Board, da ist auch ein FPGA drauf und noch ein bisschen zusätzliche Elektronik. Das erzeugt im Grunde aus diesen alten Signalen. Das hat Eingänge für CGA und glaube ich auch für dieses F-Bars-Tipal-Signal. Ich weiß es nicht ganz hundertprozentig genau. Das macht daraus ein FPGA-Signal. Dann kann man es an einem modernen Monitor benutzen. Also das kann eine Lösung sein. Aber naja, also meistens versucht man ja, die alten Monitore dann auch zu erhalten und das an den alten Monitoren zu benutzen, weil es ist nämlich tatsächlich so, dass gerade in der Konsolowelt ist es auch verbreitet. So ein LCD-Display stellt die ganzen Dinge anders dar. Und die Spiele, die sind designt für die Bildröhren, die sind designt für die physikalischen Effekte, die auf so einer Bildröhre stattfinden. Und deswegen sollte man da auch dann versuchen, einen Röhrenmonitor dann wieder zu verwenden.
Okay, das heißt, man braucht nicht nur den Computer selber, sondern auch noch mal den passenden Monitor. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man möglicherweise besser in einem Familienhaus hat, wenn man sich ernsthaft mit Vintage Computing beschäftigen möchte. Wie groß ist denn der größte Computer, den ihr habt?
Also ich habe meinen größten Rechner bei uns in Hacker Space ausgelagert. Das ist die PDP-1134A. Auch wieder PDP, also so ein Computer, den man in irgendwelchen Firmen stehen hatte oder auch in der Forschung und so. Oder als Prozessrechner. Der Rechner selbst ist gar nicht so groß. Das sind glaube ich vier Höheneinheiten. Und der ist auch gar nicht so schwer. Nur dann kommt das Netzteil, das ist wirklich sehr schwer. Und dann kommen dazu noch mal drei Festplatten, die jeweils auch vier Höheneinheiten haben und so um die 50 Kilo wiegen und dafür ganze 2, 5 Megabyte speichern können.
Was ist heute so eine aktuelle, ich werf sie dem im Medienmarkt hinterher Festplatte. Entschuldigung, in einem beliebigen Elektromarkt hinterher Festplatte. Zwei Terabyte oder sowas. Apropos, ihr habt es ja vorhin schon angesagt. Früher, falls ihr euch übrigens fragt, dieses Save-Symbol, was heute in Software immer so eine komische 4G geformt hat. Das waren Disketten, liebe Kinder. Ihr habt ja schon erzählt, dass ihr das manchmal macht für Leute, dass die von den Disketten das runterbringen. Dexter, du hattest da irgendwie noch ein extra Projekt mit Disketten.
Na ja, gut, Projekt ist zu viel gesagt. Also ich hab bei mir zu Hause, das ist so eine Sache, gerade bei den CPM-Computern wichtig ist. Und ich hab auch eine PDPL für mich im Übrigen.
Okay, ich verspreche jetzt, wir reden heute nochmal ausführlich darüber, was eine PDPL ist und warum sie so wichtig ist.
Das können wir machen. Also das ist halt so, ist halt ein 386er, auch ein alter Computer, ist nämlich so ein Compact Core Power Table 386 mit Plasma-Monitor. Sehr schönes Gerät. Da habe ich Software drauf, um Disketten zu konvertieren. Und ich habe ein externes Gehäuse, wo zwei Diskettenaufwärme drin sind, also zweimal 5, 25 Zoll und zwar einmal 1 Low Density, also für 360° Disketten und eins für 1, 2 Megabyte Disketten. Und die Software, die ich darauf verwende, ist dann diverse Konvertierprogramme, also Telegisk ist so ein Kandidat und Puta für die PDP-11 Sachen. Dann gibt es, glaube ich, auch ImageDiscs, das habe ich noch nicht so weiter getestet, und CopyQM und 22Disc. Da habe ich halt meine ganzen Diskettenkonvertierprogramme drauf. Man braucht das im Grunde, weil gerade bei den CPM-Computern hat man halt im Grunde BootDisc-Ketten, die sind auch für diesen Computer. Und das muss man halt auch mal sichern. Und deswegen, also das ist dann halt so meine Kopier-Workstation, um halt eben die Images von diesen Disketten zu machen und dass ich sie halt auf modernen Medien gebackupt habe, dass ich da halt bei Bedarf halt eine neue BootDisc-Ketten erzeugen kann.
Wie ist das mit den Datenträgern selber? Also kann man Disketten überhaupt noch kaufen? Ich glaube, ich hätte schon Probleme, irgendwie normale Disketten irgendwo zu finden. Gibt es noch Disketten, dann gerade für die alten Rechner?
Na ja, also man kriegt sie aus alten Lagerbeständen. In Auktionshäusern kann man das dann kaufen. Oder, na ja, also bei mir ist es halt so, ich kann mich nicht beklagen über das Kettenmangel. Ich habe einfach mal über die Jahre immer wieder, bei vielen dieser Computer, war halt immer noch mal ein Stapel, so ein Diskettenkasten bei, voll, das ist eigentlich kein Problem. Man schwimmt eigentlich in Disketten, wenn man so alte Computer hat, aber was halt ein Problem ist?
Es gibt ja noch aktive Nutzer von Disketten, muss man jetzt auch dazu sagen. Bist du schon mal mit der Bahn gefahren und hast einen Sitzplatz reserviert?
Okay, dann benutze ich das Kettenverstehen. Wahrscheinlich werden auch Atomkraftwerke funktioniert.
Wer soll das Internet anschließen?
Was ich mich tatsächlich gerade ernsthaft frage, ist, hat das Material, aus dem die Disketten sind, hat das irgendwie eine Zerfallzeit? Man sagte zum Beispiel von CDs, dass die nach 30 oder 40 Jahren einfach verrotten.
Das interessante ist, das erhält erstaunlich lange. Ich habe Disketten, die sind richtig alt und die funktionieren noch, aber irgendwann ist da halt auch mal Schluss. Ich denke auch, dass es irgendwann ein Problem werden wird, dass dieses Material irgendwann zerbröseln wird. Aber meine Disketten sind in erstaunlich gutem Zustand und ich bin immer wieder überrascht, wie gut diese alten Disketten noch funktionieren.
Gibt es da schon in der Szene ein Konzept oder ein Plan dafür, was passiert, wenn es mal keine Disketten mehr geben wird? Also wurde schon aktiv an einem Standard gearbeitet, um diese ganzen verschiedenen Dateisysteme und was es da alles gibt, abzubilden?
Naja, also ich habe ja schon mal kurz angesprochen, diesen HXC-Floppe-Emulator wäre so eine Lösung, die man halt, wo man im Grunde genommen das Diskettenlauf wäre komplett durch eine Hardware ersetzt. Also da gibt es schon Leute, die daran basteln und ich bin auch froh, dass das gibt und dass man das jetzt auch erkennt, dass das gebraucht wird. Also ich habe den HXC-Floppe-Emulator bei mir mal kurz getestet. Ich habe das nicht so regulär im Einsatz, weil meine Disketten da ganz gut funktionieren. Aber ich war echt erstaunt, wie gut das eigentlich funktioniert. Zumindest die Computer, die relativ standard sind, so CPC und andere, die dürften damit kein Problem haben.
Aber hat das sozusagen, also ich frage mich jetzt schon, während dieser ganzen Vintage Computing nochmal, wie ist denn das für Museen? Gibt es da vielleicht auch ein ernsthaftes wissenschaftliches Interesse? Also gerade diese ganzen alten Geräte aufrechtzuhalten, einfach um es für die Nachwelt festzuhalten? Also weil ich stelle mir so vor, ein Buch aus dem Jahr 1500, das packe ich halt ins Museum und wenn ich da irgendwie mit dem Licht aufpasse und mit der Luft, dann ist halt alles in Ordnung.
Das Problem bei den Museen ist, dass bei den meisten Museen bisher der Ansatz war, dass sie die Computer einfach tot in die Ausstellung hinter Glas stellen. Und darüber lernt man dann halt nicht wirklich viel. Wenn man so einen Computer wirklich erleben will, muss man den ja auch im Betrieb sehen, muss die Software sehen, muss damit interagieren. Und das wurde bisher sehr wenig gemacht. Da gibt es einige Museen, die sowas schon gemacht haben in den USA. Und das ist zum Beispiel auch, was das Vintage Computing Festival machen will. Also da sind die Rechner nicht aus, sondern fast alle Ausstellungsstücke laufen. Man kann sie ausprobieren.
Aber ist es dann sozusagen absehbar, weil das gerade jetzt noch so ist, wie du sagst, dass wir über einen Zeitraum von 20 oder 30 Jahren für die Nachwelt ganze Generationen von Computern verlieren und einfach nicht mehr wissen, wie die funktioniert haben, also später uns dann aus Überlieferungen behelfen müssen? Also damals, die PDP-11, die funktioniert dann so und so?
Ja, das gibt es jetzt schon. Es ist halt ganz viel Doku verloren gegangen und es ist auch einfach die Software verloren gegangen, sodass man zwar den Rechner noch hat und die Hardware vielleicht noch lauffähig wäre, aber man hat einfach nichts mehr, was man damit machen kann.
Und habt ihr Strategien, um diese Doku entsprechend auch am Leben zu halten?
Ja, es gibt zum Beispiel bitsavers.org und da werden ganz viele Handbücher gescannt und hochgeladen und auch Software von Disketten, wie gesagt, runtergezogen und veröffentlicht. Und Schaltpläne und alles sowas.
Und die sind dann einfach auf der Webseite für jeden einsehbar?
Die sind frei verfügbar, sortiert nach Herstellern und Modellen, wenn es da genug gibt. Da gibt es unglaublich viel.
Ja, für meine PDP-11 habe ich auch viel daher gezogen.
Okay, also da gibt es sagen schon ein Sammelsurium. Ich frage mich trotzdem immer noch, ob das schon organisiert ist oder ob das jetzt tatsächlich nur noch einzelne Bastler sind, also Leute wie ihr, die das für sich machen, die auch ab und zu andere Leute treffen oder ob das schon global organisiert wird. Aber vielleicht mache ich mir einfach zu viele Gedanken drüber.
Es gibt doch schon Museen, die das machen, also Computerhistorie-Museum, glaube ich.
Die hängen zusammen mit Bitsavers, das ist Elkosso, das ist der Software-Kurator da, der macht das nebenbei.
Also Bitsavers und ich glaube, da gibt es noch einen irgendwie, Manix oder so heißt der. Das macht schon einen relativ professionellen Eindruck. Die Archive sind relativ groß. Man findet auch relativ gut, was man sucht.
Das ist auch noch die Library of Congress, da ist auch noch viel so Zeug archiviert.
Okay, also da könnt ihr euch mal gerne umgucken, wenn ihr wollt. Du hast es gerade schon erwähnt, wir haben uns noch damit eingestiegen, das Vintage Computing Festival.
Das ist am 4. und 5. Oktober geöffnet für Publikum. Da gibt es Vorträge und Workshops und ganz unglaublich viele Ausstellungen zu alten Computern, alter Software, alter Peripherie und man kann ganz viel ausprobieren und selber machen. Also zum Beispiel gibt es auch ganz viel Netzwerktechnik. Wir wollen insbesondere darauf hinweisen, dass so Computer ja auch nicht einfach isoliert bestehen, sondern dass sie untereinander vernetzt werden und dann man noch ganz viel mehr damit machen kann und es wurde ein BBS-System eingerichtet, was man auch von außen erreichen kann. Ein was? Ein Bulletin Board System, also so ein Mailbox System.
Als die Modems noch gepiepst haben und du dich quasi mit deinem Modem, das du irgendwie an der Telekom vorbei geschleust an das öffentliche Telefonnetz angeschlossen hast, dann hast du dich natürlich nicht in das Internet, so wie wir es kennen, eingeloggt, sondern du hast dich bei speziellen Diensten, also bei anderen, zu einem Gegenmodem quasi eingewählt. Und dahinter stand ja ein System, wo du dann Dinge tun konntest, tatsächlich Mails abholen konntest, irgendwie dich mit anderen austauschen konntest und das ist eine BBS.
Vergleichbar mit Webforen, würde ich so.
Aber es gab ja Webforen, es gab E-Mail, es gab Dateitransfer, naja das ist eine andere Geschichte.
Gut, dann wissen wir das schon mal. Bei dem Thema Netz bleiben wir auch gleich. Wir machen gleich weiter hier. Ihr könnt auch gerne noch anrufen unter 0331 77 97 1 1 0. Oh Gott. 0331 77 97 1 1 0. Herrgott, ist es schon so spät. Wir machen gleich weiter mit den Nerd-News. Fritz Die zwei Sprechstunden. Es ist kurz nach 11 und im Chaos Radio gibt es noch eine wichtige Tradition, die wir heute natürlich fortführen wollen. Das sind die sogenannten Nerd News, zusammengetragen vom Chaos Computer Club, präsentiert von Mario Bartsch.
Spyware für alle. Auf der Enthüllungsplattform WikiLeaks ist eine Version der Spionage-Software Finfische aufgetaucht. Diese wird angeblich an Geheimdienste verkauft, um Handys und Computer von Zielpersonen überwachen zu können. Die Software funktioniert dabei als klassischer Trojaner. Auch ein Baukasten für zur Infektion der Zielgeräte ist Teil des Software-Paketes. In der Vergangenheit waren bereits Support-Dokumente des Herstellers Gamma im Internet aufgetaucht. Mit dem aktuellen Leak ist es nun möglich, dass sich interessierte Hacker und Aktivisten die Software genauer anschauen. Vielleicht gibt es ja ähnlich interessante Ergebnisse wie damals beim Bundestrojaner. Neue Super-Sicherheitslücke Shellshock ist eine neue Sicherheitslücke, die es erlaubt, viele Rechner anzugreifen, die mit UNIX-ähnlichen Betriebssystemen betrieben werden. Dazu zählt auch Apples Betriebssystem OS X. Durch Shellshock ist es möglich, auf fremden Rechnern eigene Programmcode auszuführen und das kann man ausnutzen, um Rechner komplett zu übernehmen. Trotz einer Software-Aktualisierung besteht das Problem immer noch. Falls ihr davon betroffen seid, solltet ihr die nächsten Tage also Ausschau nach einem endgültigen Update halten. Das iPhone in der Mikrowelle Die Polizei von Los Angeles hat offiziell davor gewarnt, iPhones zum Aufladen in die Mikrowelle zu legen. Falls ihr euch fragt, wie man überhaupt auf die Idee kommen kann, vor einigen Tagen geistete ein Scherzbild durchs Internet, laut dem man angeblich per Apple Wave den Akku des Handys in der Mikrowelle aufladen kann. Und anscheinend gab es tatsächlich ein paar Leute, die das geglaubt haben, was zu eingangs erwähnter Warnung der Polizei von Los Angeles führte.
Liebe Kinder, bitte versucht das nicht. Steamy von Ninety Wines hier im Chaos Radio Fritz, dem Blue Moon, wo es heute der Chaos Computer Club ist, wie er hier um Vintage Computing geht. Also wir gucken uns ein bisschen alte Computer an. Zu Gast sind dabei Zeltophil. Hallo, guten Abend. Und Lanimo.
Guten Abend.
Wir haben schon ein bisschen gesprochen, dass Vintage Computing halt, da geht es darum, wie alte Computer gearbeitet haben, dass man das mal nach erleben kann. Wir haben schon gehört, wie man das macht. Man kann es emulieren, also einfach durch Software, man kann es auch wirklich selber nachbauen. Wir haben auch schon gehört, dass Disketten ein schwieriges Thema sind. Also noch nicht, weil es gibt noch genug, aber immer mal irgendwann werden könnte. Und wie das so ist mit der Archivierung von Computern, die funktionieren überhaupt. Und jetzt sagte, zählt so viel gerade noch, während die Mikros aus waren, man kann ja Disketten auch in den Backofen tun. Entschuldigung, bitte was?
Das Problem ist halt, dass die magnetische Beschichtung davon so runterflockt. Und da ist auch ein Bindemittel drauf. Das wird halt einfach trocken oder ich weiß nicht, wie man das sagen soll. Aber wenn man das ein paar Stunden in den Backofen legt und wirklich genau auf die Temperatur achtet und da drin backen lässt, dann schmilzt sich das da alles wieder so zurecht. Das machen auch ganz viele die Audiofreaks mit ihren Tapes und so, aber auch halt für Datentapes und für Disketten kann man das machen. Und was die Leute dafür einsetzen, sind zum Teil so Obst-Trocken-Maschinen.
Gibt es noch mehr so eine Handwerkstricks für das Videobeleben alter Computer? Ich habe tatsächlich mal, also es ist jetzt nicht wirklich vintage, aber für die PlayStation 3 habe ich sowas auch mal gehört. Ich hatte so ein Hitzeproblem und da hat gesagt, ja, das ist eine kalte Lötstelle. Da könnte einfach die Platine irgendwie 40 Minuten bei 380 Grad in den Ofen legen, dann geht das wieder. Gibt es noch, also Disketten, Luft trocknen? Okay, gibt es noch mehr so eine Tricks?
Ja, also ich habe mal gehört, dass man Festplatten auch mit Wärme, wenn die verharzte Lage haben, dass man das, dass es auch angeblich helfen soll. Also ich war jetzt noch nicht so in so einer Situation. Also entweder die Festplatten, die waren unrettbar verloren oder sie gingen noch.
Ist das jetzt eigentlich bei den, ja?
Im Zweifelsfall willst du das aber bei Festplatten, wenn dir deine Daten heilig sind, eh in einen professionellen Betrieb überlassen. Also der es noch genug gibt, weil es noch genug Festplatten gibt. Wie das dann mit SSDs später aussieht, ist eine andere Sache. Aber ich glaube, wenn deine Daten heilig sind.
Nicht im Backofenleben, das ist schon was für die Basterds.
Bei den Firmen zahlt man aber vierstellige Beträge dafür.
Nee, es geht ja darum, wenn dir die wirklich heilig sind. Wenn es mal nett wäre, ist es okay.
Wir reden aber jetzt von guten unterschiedlichen Sachen. Was du meinst, ist ja sozusagen, meine Festplatte geht mir kaputt. Also verharzte Festplatten bewegt, wenn die beweglichen Teile sich verharzen, das passiert wahrscheinlich nur bei wirklich großem Alter.
Es geht ja auch eher darum, bei dieser ganzen Sache die Festplatte wieder ans Laufen zu kriegen. Die Daten sind ja meistens nicht so super wichtig. Also es gibt natürlich Situationen, da ist beides wichtig, aber eigentlich geht es ja um die Hardware, die man erhalten will.
Okay, ich sage das jetzt auch nur prophylaktisch. Wir hatten es gerade vom iPhone und der Mikrofelle.
Okay, liebe Hörer, wir gehen aus, dass ihr klug genug seid zu wissen, dass ihr eure wirklich guten, wichtigen Festplatten nicht in den Backofen tut. Aber wir haben es trotzdem jetzt noch mal gesagt. Wo wir gerade jetzt dabei sind, wir reden jetzt von Festplatten und Disketten. Und Festplatten gibt es heute immer noch. Disketten hat man vielleicht schon mal gesehen oder davon gehört. Arbeitet ihr auch mit anderen Datenträgern? Also es gab da früher auch noch Magnetbänder und Lochkarten. Oder ist das dann schon wieder zu vintage für euch?
Ja, auf jeden Fall Tapes. Da gibt es ja auch ganz verschiedene Formate. Ja, Lochkarten, Lochbänder. Das habe ich aber nicht bei mir zu Hause. Das haben wir auch nicht bei uns im Hackerspace oder so. Aber es gibt auf jeden Fall Hobbyisten, die sowas benutzen. Dann magneto-optische Laufwerke gibt es ja auch noch.
Wie sieht der Datenträger da aus?
Im Prinzip auch so, Scheiben halt.
Also auch zu Archivzwecken, sogenannte Worms, Bright Wands. Also du kannst diese Dinger nur einmal schreiben.
Wie ein ZD-Brennen quasi.
So in der Art, hat aber noch ein paar andere Vorteile, die jetzt ein bisschen komplexer sind. Du hast Archivsicherheit. Die garantieren dir auch eine relativ lange Haltbarkeit. Also das willst du halt als Unternehmen machen. Das macht man glaube ich nicht mehr. Aber das hat man bis vor ein paar Jahren gemacht. Wenn du wichtige Daten archivieren musst, auch so, dass sie über das ja auch in 10, 20 Jahren auch noch für juristische Zwecke lesbar sind. Also da musst du ja auch gesetzliche Vorgaben als Unternehmen erfüllen für gewisse Dokumente.
So, jetzt haben wir über Computernachbau und Datenträger gesprochen. Ihr seid wie gesagt auch aufgerufen anzurufen, wenn ihr selber ein Vintage Computing Erlebnis habt oder nochmal zurückschwelgen wollt zu eurem ersten Computer. 0331777110. Es hat auch den Nils genau dazu angerufen. Nils aus Neukölln. Hallo und guten Abend. Wir haben ja hier sozusagen am Anfang gesagt, es gibt vier so große Themen, nämlich Emulatoren, Homecomputerszene, Großrechner und Arcade-Automaten und Spielekonsolen. Zu diesem Thema hast du angerufen, wenn ich richtig informiert bin.
Also insbesondere Spielekonsolen, Arcade-Automaten habe ich zwar schon genutzt, aber bin ich jetzt nicht so der Sammler von... Ja, kurz eine Erwähnung erst mal. Eine Sache kurz vorher noch zu dem NTSC versus Pyle. Bei Spielekonsolen macht es wirklich viel aus, weil das macht 12% Unterschied in der Geschwindigkeit. Und wenn die Spiele nicht angepasst sind, dann wird auch die Musik langsamer, was man dann z.B. in YouTube-Videos zu Sonic sieht, ein Spiel fürs Mega-Dreif, wenn sich dann die Amerikaner fragen, ob man irgendwie auf Drogen ist oder so, weil die ganze Musik einfach mal ein Stück langsamer ist, als sie es gewohnt sind.
Wenn man sozusagen ein amerikanisches Spiel auf der europäischen Hardware spielt?
Nein, wenn man ein europäisches Spiel ganz normal spielt auf unserer Hardware, dann ist es durch die 50 Hz, die wir hier verwenden, 12% langsamer, wenn es nicht angepasst worden ist, als das Spiel im Original.
Okay, verstehe. Du beschäftigst dich damit mit alten Konsolen, wie man spielen kann. Du bist auch Teil eines Podcasts, der dich damit beschäftigt.
Genau. Ich bin Teil vom Retro-Circle. Ich mache das mit zwei Freunden zusammen. Wir sprechen einmal im Monat über ein ausgewähltes Spiel. Es sind 8-16-Bit-Konsolen und teilweise auch Heimcomputerspiele, aber hauptsächlich aus dem LucasArts-Bereich.
Wenn ihr das macht, schwägt ihr das auch in Erinnerung oder spielt ihr das Spiel jeweils noch mal durch?
Wir spielen nach Möglichkeit das Spiel noch mal durch. Entweder je nachdem, welche Hardware man zur Verfügung hat auf Originalkonsole oder einem Emulator. Ein Emulator hat natürlich den Vorteil, dass man da auch mal zwischendrin abspeichern kann und wieder laden und dadurch das Spiel einfach mal schneller durchspielen kann, also auf der Originalkonsole. Aber das Feeling ist halt schon auf der Originalkonsole ein anderes. Ich habe hier auch auf meinem Tisch direkt vor mir irgendwie ein N64 und Super Nintendo und zwei alte Game Boys liegen, die vor einem Fernseher stehen.
Das heißt, du würdest die Original-Hardware immer vorziehen, einem Emulator?
Kommt auf den Einsatzweck drauf an. Also zum Beispiel, ich habe da jetzt ein längeres Rollenspiel vor mir und das habe ich im Original für Super Nintendo und ich werde es dann wahrscheinlich trotzdem im Emulator spielen, weil ich es dann auf meinem Telefon spielen kann, weil ich immer dabei habe. Und auf der Original-Hardware habe ich dann vielleicht eine Stunde am Abend oder so und auf meinem Telefon habe ich es halt in den ganzen U-Bahn-Fahrten und so etwas noch mit dabei. Aber an sich ist Original-Hardware schon besser als Emulator. Es gibt auch Leute, die so ein bisschen abschätzig gucken, gerade in der Retro-Spiele-Bereich, wenn die Leute mit Emulatoren spielen, weil ich aber nicht ganz so verstehen kann, auch wenn es ab und zu Probleme gibt mit Emulatoren.
Gibt es denn auch diese Zwischenstufe? Jetzt gibt es ja gerade zu sagen, entweder du hast die Original-Hardware oder du spielst auf deinem Smartphone. Gibt es auch dieses, wir bauen Original-Hardware nach und schließen Kontrolle an einen modernen Rechner an?
Da gibt es zwar mehrere Zwischenstufen. Fangen wir doch mal an. Man kann ja den Emulator haben und dann holt man sich einen USB-Adapter, um sein Original-Pad an den Rechner anzuschließen, was es schon mal ein bisschen besser macht. Also allein vom Gefühl her. Dann gibt es so ein Ding, das nennt sich Retro, wird leider nicht mehr hergestellt. Da kann man ein Original-Modul reinstecken, das an den Rechner anschließen. Das hat dann noch Controller-Ports. Und dann spielt man das Modul aber über den Emulator. Aber man kann halt sein Original-Modul benutzen und kann auch die Speicherstände davon benutzen. Also die Module wurden ja früher mit Batterien ausgestattet, womit man gespeichert hat, weil man ja, ja, das waren ja Roms die Module und man musste irgendwie speichern. Das wurde halt über Batterie realisiert, wenn es kein Passport-System gab. Hat übrigens auch das Problem, dass die Batterien langsam alle werden.
Das heißt, das Rollenspiel, das ich vor 15 Jahren angefangen habe, muss ich dann bald mal zu Ende spielen, weil sonst der Spielstand verloren geht.
Ja genau, genau, genau das. Es gibt natürlich, du kannst die Batterie austauschen. Du musst mal ein bisschen aufpassen, ich habe bei meinen ersten Versuchen jedes Mal die Batterie kurz geschlossen, worauf die Batterie leer war. Dann gibt es so Tricks, wie kann ich die Batterie im laufenden Betrieb austauschen oder wie kann ich es so austauschen, dass beim Austausch meine Speicherstände nicht verloren gehen. Das ist dann so was auf dem G-Moy, wie Spiele auf dem G-Moy Advanced FP, weil die Modulhöhe da nur halb so hoch ist wie beim G-Moy und dann kann man quasi das offene Modul reinstecken und während das Gerät an ist die Batterie austauschen, wenn es halt die ganze Zeit unter Strom ist.
Da geht es einiges an Abenteuer. Du hast gerade gesagt, mit Emulatoren gibt es ab und zu Probleme. Ist das dann quasi nicht mehr die originale Spielerfahrung?
Na, zum einen gibt es halt das Problem, dass, also ich habe mal einen Artikel gelesen, der meint, das ist ein Super Nintendo, was irgendwie mit 2 Mhz oder sowas läuft, braucht einen, um es originalgetreu zu emulieren, einen 3, 1 GHz Rechner oder so. Wenn man alles emulieren wollte von dieser Konsole. Und es gibt halt Spiele, zum Beispiel eben auf dem Super Nintendo gibt es ein Spiel Speedy Gonzales, das kann man auf einem Emulator nicht durchspielen, weil sie es irgendwie nicht schaffen, irgendwas von diesem Spiel zu emulieren und dann bleibt das Spiel mit dem drin hängen. Und bei anderen Emulatoren, also zum Beispiel, ja, wie der Super Nintendo, weil es ist halt schon ein bisschen komplexer, so von den Sonderchips, die da mal mit dabei waren. Wenn die Hardware halt langsamer ist, hat man zum Beispiel bestimmte von diesen Spezialeffekten, die sehen dann nicht mehr ganz so gut aus, bzw. werden halt fehlerhaft dargestellt. Und das hat man natürlich auf der Original-Hardware nicht.
Jetzt würde man vielleicht denken, wenn Konsolen emuliert werden, dann ist das komplizierter, weil da muss ich die ganze Hardware zwischen. Während, wenn ich jetzt, sagen, spiele aus einem alten Rechner, also keine Ahnung, C64 oder Migrant, das müsste ja eigentlich ganz einfach gehen. Das sind ja schließlich alles Computer, die nur schneller geworden sind. Stimmt das so, oder ist das ein Trugschluss?
Also ein C64 läuft ja, das wissen wahrscheinlich deine Gäste besser, der läuft doch auch ein Z80, oder?
Nee, das war 6502 in dem Fall.
Ja, aber sowas wie den Spectrum, der lief ja auf dem Z80. Also es gibt halt Konsolen, die zum Beispiel auf dem Z80 laufen, worauf auch alte Homecomputer liefen, oder ein Mega Drive läuft auf einem 65000er. Das war ein Amiga, wenn mich nicht alles täuscht, der läuft auch mit einem ähnlichen Prozessor. Also da sind, glaube ich, die gleichen Probleme da. Also mit der Homecomputer-Emulation kenne ich mich nicht so gut aus, aber da sind, glaube ich, genau die gleichen Probleme da. Weil man ja bei den Rechnern heutzutage ist ja alles x86-kompatibel, aber früher gab es ja nicht nur Intel-Rechner. Also nicht nur x86-kompatible Rechner, mal abgesehen von so Problemen wie der Geschwindigkeit. Also ich kann mich schon erinnern, als ich auf dem x86 gespielt habe, da ich XT-Spieler nicht spielen konnte, weil die zu schnell ließen.
Also vieles mit Schreiben kenne ich auch.
Die trotz abgeschaltetem Turbo.
Ja genau, trotz abgeschaltetem Turbo war es unspielbar schnell. Alle Freunde von meinem Bruder hatten nur XTs.
Das sind Probleme. Ich habe jetzt noch zwei Fragen. Das eine ist, wenn man da so einsteigen will, diese alten Emulationen von alten Konsolen, wo macht man das am besten? Gibt es da einen einfachen Einstieg? Kannst du was empfehlen an Apps, weil du sagtest, du spielst auf dem Smartphone oder so was?
Also es gibt halt Google. Man sollte googeln, weil das Runterladen der Roms ist. Das ist so ähnlich, wie wenn ich Musik runterlade oder so.
Das wäre jetzt meine nächste Frage gewesen. Wie sieht das eigentlich juristisch aus, wenn man so alte Computerspiele sich anscheinend einfach so irgendwie runterzieht?
Ja, das ist, also es gibt die mehr von, wenn man es nur 24 Stunden zieht, ist es legal oder wenn man halt das Modul, also selbst wenn man das Modul besitzt, ist es wohl nicht erlaubt, sich das Rom trotzdem runterzuladen. Also es gibt zwar einige Seiten, die so alles haben, was das Herz begehrt und die auch über Jahre nicht geschlossen werden. Also es scheint sich niemand drum zu kümmern, aber legal ist es nicht. Deswegen braucht man dann an sich sowas wie die Retro, die es eben erlaubt, das Originalmodul, was man dann auf eBay kauft, auf seinem Rechner zu spielen.
Okay, also es ist eigentlich verboten, aber es kümmert sich niemand drum.
Wer jetzt noch alte Spiele hat, die jetzt keine Hardware-Emulation erfordern, weil sie durchaus irgendwie noch aus den späten 80ern, frühen 90ern stammen, so klassische jetzt wie Indiana Jones beispielsweise, die brauchen auch nicht mehr Hardware-Emulationen. Da gibt es ScumWM, das emuliert nur das Spielesystem. Also dort haben sich dann quasi das Studio oder sogar mehrere Studios hingesetzt und quasi so einen Spielewelten-Interpreter geschrieben.
Ja, Scum funktioniert halt für alles, was von LucasArts ist.
Genau, LucasArts.
Also bis zum letzten Monkey, bis zum Monkey Island 3 oder so. Im Fandango gibt es so einen eigenen Emulator nochmal. Das war so das erste 3D-Adventure in dem Bereich. Und dann funktioniert Scum noch für ein paar andere Spiele. Also das geht auf jeden Fall bei Modulen, also bei den Konsolen. Und es gibt halt die DOS-Box für alte DOS-Spiele. Wenn man da einen USB-Floppy-Laufwerk hat und die alten Floppys noch, oder CDs noch, beziehungsweise bei gog.com, kann man sich die alten Spiele auch kaufen direkt. Da gibt es ja einen Schick mit DOS-Box und Artwork und sonst was.
Warum ich das...
Da kann man die halt direkt los spielen. Da kann man sich die kaufen, runterladen und direkt los spielen. Die haben sich halt um die Lizenzen und alles gekümmert. Bei Konsolen hat man halt immer das Problem, dass man ein Modul hat. Und wie kriegt man das Modul an den Rechner ran? Und Rom-Dumper gibt es halt auch nicht so wirklich.
Also Dinge, die sie sagen, die sie zu kaufen. Nils, dann vielen Dank für diesen Einblick in das Vintage Gaming, könnte man sagen. Und wie heißt er? Retro-Circle.
Retro-Circle, genau. Und dann Retro-Circle.de.
Alles klar. Dann vielen Dank und viel Spaß beim Spielen. Jetzt haben wir auch einen kleinen Ausflug ins Gaming gemacht. Da sind ja hier nicht so die Experten am Start, wie ich mir das sagen lassen. Aber trotzdem an euch nochmal die Frage, dieses rechte Problem. Bei Spielen liegt das so ein bisschen auf der Hand. Das sind halt die künstlerische Werke etc. Ihr arbeitet jetzt mit sehr alten Computern. Bei Windows gab es ja auch immer das Problem von Raubkopien. Wie ist denn das überhaupt bei so ganz alten Computern? Spielt das da auch eine Rolle? Oder spielt das da, wie bei den ganz alten Spielen, theoretisch eine Rolle, aber es interessiert eigentlich keinen mehr? Oder war früher alles open source und jeder durfte damit alles machen? Oder fällt das einfach unter den Tisch und man interessiert sich nicht dafür?
Das spielt schon immer noch eine Rolle. Also die Firmen wurden ja immer aufgekauft und dann wieder von irgendjemanden aufgekauft und abgestoßen und von irgendjemanden aufgekauft. Und die Rechte von den Betriebssystemen und der Software so liegen ganz oft noch bei irgendwelchen Firmen, die man auch erst raussuchen muss, die man gar nicht mehr kennt und so. Aber die Rechte gibt es immer noch und es wäre immer noch illegal, diese Software zu kopieren und zu verwenden.
Haben diese Firmen, die die Rechte dann halten, auch irgendwann Interesse, dass es noch weiter benutzt wird? Und forschen die danach oder hört man von denen eigentlich dann trotzdem nichts?
Teilweise, das kommt ganz auf die Anwendung an, aber ich kenne keinen Hobbyisten, der verklagt worden wäre.
Puh, hoffen wir, dass das so bleibt. Man weiß immer nie, auf was für Komische die in den Leuten kommen. Dexter Runzel, Grad die Stirn?
Naja, also der Punkt ist halt, also ich kenne auch niemanden, der als Hobbyist da überhaupt Probleme mit hatte. Ich habe auch noch nie, bis es da auch keine Fälle bekannt. Aber was ich persönlich halt nicht mache, ist die Disc-Images, die ich anfertige und die ROM-Dumps von meinen Computern. Bei den Computern sollte man das nämlich auch machen, weil die ROMs können sie auch vergessen nach einer Zeit. Die stelle ich halt auf meiner Webseite nicht online, weil ich nämlich da, weiß ich nicht, nicht dass da irgend so ein windiger Rechtsanwalt dann da eine Stelle markt mitmachen zu können.
Also schon aus den Gründen, dass man sich da nicht ausliefern will der unklaren juristischen Situation. Kann das dann auch dazu führen, dass das möglicherweise dann irgendwann in Vergessenheit gerät? Also ich überlege jetzt gerade, du machst das halt nicht. Möglicherweise hast du einen Computer, den du halt letzter hast und wenn du halt keine Ahnung beschließt, ich fahre auf mit dem Scheiß, lösche das alles, dann ist das halt weg.
Der Punkt ist also, man sieht ja auf meiner Webseite, welche Computer ich habe und wenn jemand diesen Computer hat und ein Problem hat, naja, dann helfe ich sicherlich gerne.
Gut, wir werden gleich nochmal über zwei Dinge sprechen, nämlich einerseits darüber, wie es ist, ein altes Internet für Vintage Computer zu nachzubauen tatsächlich und dann nochmal so ein bisschen generellen Rundumschlag zu machen, wie das hin ist, was man an einem alten Computer alles lernen kann. Vor allem noch ein bisschen Musik und danach die Nachrichten.
Zur Zeit geht's bei Fritz um eine der wichtigsten Sachen der Welt.
Shoppen?
Fußball!
Manche machen's alleine, manche zu zweit und einige sogar zu sechs oder acht. Noch ein Tipp. Wohnen? Äh, richtig. Wohnen. Zur Zeit wird hier ungewohnt viel gewohnt.
Vier Wände und ein Radio.
Wer wohnt wie wo? Gar nicht mal so unspannend. Und zu gewinnen gibt's auch was zu gewinnen. Die streng limitierte und unkäufliche Fritz-Fußmatte. Da steht ihr doch drauf. Guckt's euch mal an.
Wohnen Mit Mario Bartsch. Der iranische Präsident Rouhani hat dem Westen vorgeworfen, für das Erstarken des Terrorismus in der Welt verantwortlich zu sein. Vor der Vollversammlung der Vereinten Nationen, sagte Rouhani, militärische Aggressionen gegen den Irak und Afghanistan und eine falsche Einschätzung der Entwicklung in Syrien seien Beispiele für die verfehlte Strategie im Mittleren Osten. Terrorismus sei das Ergebnis von Armut, Unterentwicklung, Demütigung und Ungerechtigkeit. Rouhani hält außerdem ein internationales Abkommen über das Atomprogramm seines Landes bereits im November für möglich. Dafür müsse sich der Westen allerdings flexibel zeigen, sagte Rouhani. US-Präsident Obama hat die Ebola-Epidemie in Westafrika als Gefahr für die globale Sicherheit bezeichnet. Es handele sich um einen Gesundheitsnotfall, der eine internationale Antwort verlange, sagte Obama in New York. Unter der Leitung von UN-Generalsekretär Bahnenberiten hochrangige Vertreter über Hilfen für die betroffenen Staaten. EU-Kommissionspräsident Barroso kündigte an, die EU werde ihre Hilfen um weitere 30 Millionen auf insgesamt 180 Millionen Euro aufstocken. In Deutschland meldeten sich für die Hilfe in den westafrikanischen Ebola-Gebieten laut Verteidigungsministerin von der Leyen bereits etwa 4.500 Freiwillige. Der Etat für Schulhelfer soll laut der Bildungsverwaltung in diesem Jahr um 750.000 Euro aufgestockt werden. Durch diese Erhöhung sollen zusätzliche Schulhelfer Kinder mit Behinderungen im Schulalltag unterstützen. Das zusätzliche Geld soll es laut Bildungsverwaltung geben, weil immer mehr Kinder mit Behinderungen in den Regelschulen lernen. Ihre Zahlnahmen gegenüber dem vergangenen Jahr umfasst ein Fünftel auf mehr als 2.000 zu. Schulhelfer unterstützen beispielsweise Kinder im Rollstuhl auf ihrem Weg durch das Schulgebäude. Bei der Lufthansa drohen wieder Streiks der Piloten. Die Gewerkschaft Cockpit hat heute die gerade erst wieder aufgenommenen Tarifgespräche mit Lufthansa für gescheitert erklärt und Arbeitsniederlegungen angekündigt. Die Gewerkschaft kämpft dafür, dass die betriebsinterne Frührente für die Lufthansa-Piloten nicht abgeschafft wird. Auch die Tarifverhandlungen zwischen der Deutschen Bahn und der Gewerkschaft deutscher Lokomotivführer GDL sind erneut gescheitert. Ob es zu Streiks kommt, entscheiden die Gewerkschafter bis zum 2. Oktober in einer Uhrabstimmung. Die aktuellen Temperaturen liegen in Berlin-Pankow bei 12, in Wannsee bei 14 Grad, Potsdam, Prenzla und Eisenhütten statt Melden 12, Wittenberge 14 Grad. Heute Nacht ist es meist stark bewölkt und es kann hier und da auch etwas regnen. Die Temperaturen sinken auf 12 bis 10 Grad. Am Tag wird es dann wolkig und trüb mit gelegentlichem Regen bei maximal 16 bis 17 Grad. Stadtverkehr Berlin, A100 Stadtring Richtung Wedding. Der Britzer Tunnel ist wegen Wartungsarbeiten zwischen Buschkruge Allee und Gradestraße bis 5 Uhr früh gesperrt. A115 Avers Stadt auswärts zwischen Dreieckfunkturm und Hüttenweg ist die rechte Spur wegen Bauarbeiten gesperrt. Vorsicht auf der A10 nördlicher Berliner Ring Richtung Dreieck-Hafeland. Zwischen Dreieck-Pankow und Mühlenbeck liegen Reifenteile auf der Fahrbahn. Tiergarten, die Straße des 17. Juni, ist zwischen Nizagrabinstraße und Ebertstraße gesperrt wegen des Berlin-Marathons am Sonntag. Und noch eine Meldung von der B158 Angermünde Richtung Berlin. Zwischen Wollenberger Schmiede und Steinbeck gab es einen schweren Unfall. Dort ist die B158 voll gesperrt. Wo es geht, gute Fahrt.
Fritz ist eine Produktion des RBB.
Und wenn ihr diesen Sound mögt, oder diesen Sound, dann hört doch mal den Fritz Soundgarden mit RGR-Güse. Am Montagabend ab 20 Uhr und im Radio. Oder jederzeit auf fritz.de Musikstreams.
Hallo und herzlich willkommen zurück zum letzten Mal, zur letzten halben Stunde zum Chaos Radio im Blue Moon. Der Sendung, die hier manchmal stattfindet, wo der Chaos Computer Club das Studio übernimmt. Heute in Gestalt von Zeltophil. Hallo und guten Abend.
Guten Abend.
Es geht um alte Computer. Und wir haben schon viel gelernt in den letzten anderthalb Stunden über diese alten Computer, warum man das macht, wie man das macht, was es dafür Probleme geben kann, was man da auch darauf zocken kann, haben wir gerade gehört in der letzten halben Stunde. Und Dexter hat noch sozusagen ein spannendes Projekt gehabt. Er hat nicht nur sozusagen, nicht nur daran, dass man einen alten Computer tatsächlich noch mal jetzt betreiben kann, sondern er hat auch versucht, Internet zu machen für diese Computer. Dexter, bitte, was ist da los? Also erst mal auch hier die Frage, warum macht man das? Weil so ein Internet damals muss doch tierisch langsam gewesen sein.
Ja, das war in der Tat auch sehr langsam. Also das Projekt, was ich da gemacht habe, es hieß Bildschirmtricks. Und da ging es um BTX. Also BTX heißt ja eigentlich Bildschirmtext, aber ich habe das Bildschirmtricks genannt, weil irgendwann hat sich der Chaos Computer Club mal scherzhaft über BTX geäußert und das als Bildschirmtricks bezeichnet. Deswegen hieß mein Projekt so.
Du musst, glaube ich, erst mal ganz kurz erklären, was BTX eigentlich ist.
Ja, ich glaube auch. Also BTX war ein Online-Dienst. Und das war so in den 80ern. Da ist dieser Online-Dienst von der Post gestartet worden. Und das war im Grunde genommen so ein Terminal-Dienst. Also man hatte halt bei den Benutzern, also der Endpunkt war im Grunde einfach ein Terminal. Also im Grunde, naja.
Terminal heißt ein Bildschirm, der nur aus Textzeichen besteht?
Ja, also es ist so ausgesehen, hat das im Grunde wie ein großes Telefon mit einem Bildschirm drin. Also ein Röhrenbildschirm, wohl bemerkt. Und eine Tastatur. Also Volltastatur zur Texteingabe. Und an diesem Terminal hingen Modem, oder das Modem war direkt eingebaut. Und damit hat man dann automatisch, also man konnte nicht selber wählen, was man anwählen will, sondern das hat dann automatisch von der Post, den Großrechner, in Ulm, glaube ich, war der, angewählt und der hat dann eine sogenannte BTX-Seite ausgeliefert, die dann auf dem Terminal angezeigt worden ist. Und da haben, naja, man hat da auch noch nicht so viel Erfahrung mit Online-Diensten gehabt und man hat da also gedacht, ja, man macht dann damit bei, ja, so Versandhausquelle und, ja, man kauft dann online ein, macht Online-Shopping. In Frankreich gab es ein ähnliches System, es hieß Minitel, das war ein Riesenerfolg, das System von der Post ist, naja, gescheitert.
Wie immer, wenn die Deutschen versuchen, was Innovatives im Internet zu machen.
Das ist vor allem an den Preisen gescheitert. Also die Endgeräte waren viel zu teuer und wenn man sich heute so ein altes Endgerät auch ansieht und da reinschaut, dann weiß man auch, warum. Weil da nämlich nur der teuerste Kram verkauft, verbaut worden ist. Also das ist wirklich in alles wunderbar, tolle Technik, aber viel zu teuer für den Endkunden.
Und du hast die nachgebaut?
Ja, also das, ja, im Grunde, das Terminal habe ich nicht nachgebaut. Ich hatte halt irgendwann mal so ein Terminal und habe mir gedacht, okay, es wäre eigentlich ganz schön, wenn man jetzt damit noch, ja, sich in BTX anmelden könnte und ein bisschen, na ja, BTXen hat man da früher zugesagt wohl, also ein bisschen BTXen kann. Und na ja, also ich habe das BTX nie selber miterlebt. Also ich weiß, wusste, dass es irgendwie das gab.
Also ich kenne das auch nur noch davon, dass die Züge, die ICE-Züge, bevor sie renoviert wurden, tatsächlich noch teilweise BTX-Terminals eingebaut hatten. Die waren dann offline, aus ganz unverständlichen Gründen. Aber das war in den ersten ICE-Zügen der ersten Generationen war da tatsächlich vorgesehen, dass man da während der Fahrt BTXen könnte.
Die Zukunft.
Die Zukunft. Mit dem Internet klappt das ja bis heute. Egal, aber wie gesagt, daher kann man das vielleicht mal gesehen haben, weil das da so im Gang mehr oder weniger auffällig so ein etwas Retroteil rumstand. Das ist so ein BTX-Terminal gewesen.
Ja, also wenn man sich so ein bisschen mal vorstellen will, wie das damals wohl ausgesehen hat, dann ist es ganz gut, wenn man sich mal den Tele-Text vom Fernseher anguckt. Das ist so ähnlich war das im Grunde. Also Kletzchen-Grafik, es konnte ein bisschen mehr. Man konnte so eigene Zeichensätze nachladen und ein bisschen Voll-Grafik ging auch. Ja, wie gesagt, ich habe halt so ein Terminal bei mir rumliegen gehabt und wollte das halt wiederbeleben. Also man kriegt die auch in Online-Auktionshäusern eigentlich ganz günstig. Das Problem ist halt nur, die Dinger sind halt relativ tot, man kann damit nicht viel machen. Ich bin dann halt hingegangen und habe mir diese Modems angeguckt. Die hießen DBT-03, das war dieses Postmodem, was da angeschlossen wurde. Habe das so ein bisschen reverse-ingeniert, also ein bisschen im Grunde geguckt, wie das funktioniert, was da für Signale anliegen und in welchen Zeiträumen die Signale angelegt werden müssen. Und da war ziemlich viel, musste man da rausfinden. Also die Baudraten waren bekannt.
Was sind Baudraten?
Das sind die Geschwindigkeiten, wie schnell der Downlink und der Uplink ist.
Wie schnell war das damals?
Also ich kann sein, dass ich mich jetzt irre. Ich glaube, der Downlink zum Terminal war 1200 baut und der Uplink war 75 baut.
Wie viel ist das in Megabyte pro Sekunde?
Das weiß ich jetzt nicht, das ist ganz, ganz wenig. Man kann sehen, wie die Seiten übertragen werden, wie sie sich aufbaut.
Also Zeichen für Zeichen?
Ja, da kann man noch ein bisschen zugucken. Das ist nicht besonders schnell. Da waren zum Beispiel so Dinge drin, wie das Terminal zum Beispiel, also die Hörtöne vom Telefon, also dieses Freizeichen und das Piepsen, das hört das Terminal durch das Modem durch. Da musste man also ein bisschen basteln, bis das mal lief. Das hat sehr lange gedauert, aber irgendwann lief es dann. Und dann konnte ich von meinem PC aus über einen Mikrocontroller, der da als Bautraten-Converter lief, erst mal testweise BTX-Seiten auf diesem Terminal anzeigen. Und der nächste Schritt war dann halt, einen etwas größeren Mikrocontroller daneben zu setzen. Und naja, damals gab es das noch nicht so mit Raspberry Pi und Arduino, das gab es damals alles noch gar nicht. Da hatte halt ein Kollege von mir, der hatte halt gerade so ein Projekt für Mikrocontroller fertig gehabt, wo es darum ging, Internet mit Mikrocontrollern zu machen. Also so richtig Ethernet-Kabel reinstecken und dann auf Webseiten zugreifen via HTTP. Das ging, also das Projekt heißt OpenMCP. Und darauf, der Basis, habe ich dann ein System gebaut, was eben einen HTTP-Request, also im Grunde ein HTTP-Request ist das, was der Internet- Browser macht, wenn er eine Internetseite bei einem Server anfragt. Und da ich auf meinem Web-Server schon diesen Server hatte, diesen HTTP-Server, der normalerweise Webseiten ausliefert, habe ich halt mit dem Mikrocontroller ein HTTP-Request gemacht. Und der Server hat dann halt keine HTML-Seite ausgeliefert, sondern eine BTX-Seite, die ich so ein bisschen HTML-mäßig encodiert hatte.
Aber das Ergebnis war sozusagen, dass du dieses BTX-Terminal quasi benutzen konntest in Originalgeschwindigkeit.
Genau, also das ist ja dann so, der Mikrocontroller hat die Seite entgegengenommen, hat sie dann konvertiert und auf dem Terminal angezeigt. Und dann hatte man eben die Möglichkeit, von dem Terminal aus, diese Seiten auf dem Web-Server anzufangen. Also der Punkt war halt nicht nur, irgendwie einen Mikrocontroller zu haben, wo man irgendwie, der das direkt am PC betreibt, sondern eine autonome Box, die von ihren Abmaßen auch noch in das DBT-03-Modemgehäuse gepasst hat. Das habe ich so gemacht, dass es da reingepasst hat, dass man im Grunde, dem erstmal nicht so ansieht, dass es manipuliert wurde, aber im Grunde eben, dass man ein autonomes BTX-Terminal irgendwo in die Ecke stellen kann und in die nächste Ethernet-Dose einen Ethernet-Kabel steckt und dann im Grunde, wie früher die BTX-Seiten aufrufen kann.
Also es hört sich an wie so eine Art Gesellen- oder Meisterstück des Vintage Computing. Wird sowas irgendwo ausgestellt?
Naja, ich habe mich entschlossen, es auf dem VCFB auszustellen. Da wird es halt dieses Terminal dann zu sehen geben mit dieser Box. Ich hoffe, dass das Internet alles funktioniert. Neue Seiten werde ich jetzt bis dahin wahrscheinlich nicht gestalten können. Da wird man dann irgendwie, weiß ich nicht, wo ich das mal auf den Chaos Communication Box, ich glaube, es war 22C3, vorgestellt habe, wird man diese Seiten dann auch wieder sehen. Das hat auch alles eine bisschen Grenzen. Ich habe es natürlich nur bis zu gewissen Punkten entwickelt, also zum Beispiel Texteingabefelder fehlen. Also man kann BTX mit Nummern und Namen ansprechen. Es gibt automatische Weiterleitungen, aber das war es dann auch schon. Aber doch, eigentlich funktioniert es ganz gut.
Kann man das auch jetzt von aus benutzen oder nur mit diesem Terminal?
Naja, also wenn jetzt jemand sich dieses Projekt, man kann es ja runterladen, sich eine Platine macht und das alles baut und die Firmware da in den Mikro-Controller flasht, dann kann er sein Terminal nehmen, das da anschließend in die Ethernet-Dosis stecken und dann auf meinen Webserver zugreifen und die BTX-Seiten sehen, die ich dahinterlegt habe.
Aber es ist nicht so, dass man sagen, mit einem normalen PC dahinsurfen kann, dann mal BTX quasi emuliert erleben?
Ja, also es geht schon. Man kann natürlich auf diesen HTT-Server zugreifen, aber man kommt dann in dieses entkodierte Format, man kann da eigentlich nichts sehen. Man sieht noch ein bisschen ASCII-Text und ein paar Steuerzeichen, die so in HTML-Textspitzklammern, also es ist eine hexadezimale Zahl, die da ist.
Aber gut, so kann man BTX emulieren. Also, das ist echt ein krasses Projekt. Ich muss mir das mal angucken. Das gibt es zu sehen, wie gesagt, auf dem Vintage Computing Festival Berlin. Sag noch mal kurz, wann das ist, wo das ist.
Das ist am 4. und 5. Oktober im Pergamon-Polley in den Räumen der Medienwissenschaft der HU Berlin.
Okay, da kann man also die ganzen Sachen, die wir heute hier in der Sendung besprochen haben, sich mal sozusagen live angucken, also vielleicht nicht alle, aber sozusagen ein Gefühl dafür bekommen, was das live bedeutet, Vintage Computing zu machen. Ich würde zum Abschluss gerne noch zwei kurze Fragen stellen. Das eine ist, zwischendurch tauchte immer wieder der Name PDP auf, also PDP 11, PDP 8. Warum ist gerade dieser Rechner so wichtig? Also man hat jetzt bei euch viel gehört, aber das ist schon auch ein Name, der wenn man sich so ein bisschen mit dem Computer beschäftigt, der immer wieder mal auftaucht. Was war an diesem Rechner so besonders? Warum ist der jetzt gerade so ein Meilenstein anscheinend? Ist das einfach einer, der noch übrig ist, deswegen mögen Retro-Computer Leute den? Oder war der wirklich so wichtig damals, wichtiger als andere Geräte?
Die PDP 8 war damals im Prinzip der erste Rechner, der sich auch eine kleinere Firma leisten konnte und die auch klein genug war, dass man sie bei sich reinstellen konnte, die nicht einen doppelten Boden brauchte, eine Klimaanlage, die einen normalen Stromanschluss hat und so. Also es war einfach der erste Rechner, der wirklich viel verkauft wurde und ganz viel eingesetzt wurde und auch richtig lange lief. Also PDPs, nicht gerade die 8, aber andere PDPs wurden ja noch bis in die 80er Jahre verkauft.
Und hatte der keinen Nachfolger mehr, dass er so lange durchgehalten hat?
Doch, es gab einen Nachfolger. Das war ein VEX-Computer von Digitell. VEX steht für Virtual Address Extension. Und am Anfang war das tatsächlich eine Erweiterung von der PDP 11, aber später dann eine eigene Architektur.
Aber der war nicht so wichtig sozusagen, weil der ist ja heute gar nicht aufgetaucht.
Der war schon wichtig. Es war auch ein sehr klassischer Industrierechner, der eigentlich auch weit verbreitet eingesetzt worden ist, wo Fertigungsstraßen mitgesteuert worden sind. Auch als Prozessrechner für alles mögliche in der Medizin. Es war im Grunde der Nachfolge dieser PDP-Computer.
Wenn ihr euch jetzt, ihr beschäftigt euch mit diesen alten Computern. Was ich ja feststelle, bei den neuen Computern ist, die wandern immer mehr in den Hintergrund. Man sieht immer weniger, was da überhaupt passiert. Sowohl bei den eigentlichen Computern, die immer dünner und schmaler werden, die man nicht mal einfach aufschraubt und mal eine Festplatte austauscht, als auch Smartphones. Das sind ja auch mittlerweile vollwertigste Computer, die aber sozusagen unsichtbar sind. Also was dahinter passiert. Jetzt habt ihr damit zu tun und seht, geht in die Eingeweiden dieser alten Maschinen. Lernt man oder glaubt ihr, dass das den eigenen Umgang mit Computern verändert? Oder kann man daraus noch was absehen, was sich dann auch heute übertragen lässt?
Also man kann daran sehr viel einfacher lernen als heutzutage, wie Computer eigentlich funktionieren. Ich habe mir aus dem Grund mal ein C64 geholt. Also eigentlich wollte ich eine Demo dafür schreiben, aber habe ich natürlich nie gemacht. Aber so ein C64 ist ein Computer, da kann man noch die Hardware wirklich vollständig verstehen. Da kann man noch verstehen, wie so ein Betriebssystem funktioniert und überhaupt die Software, die darauf läuft. Und daraus aufbauen kann man dann natürlich auch leichter verstehen, wie heutzutage Computer gebaut werden. Aber auch am C64 kann man einfach noch mal was reparieren, mit einem Lötkolben drin rumfuchteln, was man sich in einem heutigen Notebook halt eher nicht mehr trauen würde, weil das alles so klein ist. Und wenn man auch was kaputt macht, zum Teil die Tipps und Bauteile einfach gar nicht mehr kaufen kann selber.
Würdet ihr euch das wünschen, dass heute sozusagen Computer genauso reparierbar sind wie die alten? Oder ist es schon sozusagen jetzt im praktikablen Alltagsgebrauch eigentlich geil, dass man die Maschine halt nicht basteln muss, sondern im Zweifel austauscht?
Na ja, also moderne Computers sind halt einfach Wegwerfcomputer. Wenn sie veraltet sind oder kaputt sind, schmeißt man sie weg. Also wenn man jetzt quasi in der modernen Welt einen Computer haben will, der einfach ist, wo man mit basteln will, dann sind eigentlich Mikrocontroller eine ganz gute Option. Weil das sind im Grunde Computer, die sind so auf dem Leistungsniveau dieser alten Rechner, aber halt auch relativ leicht zu programmieren. Die werden hergestellt, sind halt in Chip-Form. Mikrocontroller ist so ein kleiner Chip. Aber auch da hat man eine Serie-Schnittstelle. Da kann man dann ein Terminal-Programm dranhängen. Und da kann man dann auch, wenn man möchte, ein Betriebssystem programmieren oder eine kleine Shell mit I.O.-Ausgänge schalten, was auch immer. So ein Mikrocontroller ist übrigens auch sehr, sehr praktisch bei Retro-Computing-Geschichten. Zum Beispiel beim BTX-Projekt, da waren auch Mikrocontroller im Einsatz.
Gibt es sonst noch so, wenn man jetzt dieses Chaosradio gehört und sich denkt, okay, ich möchte mir das auch mal näher angucken. Wir wissen schon, wir können zum Vintage Computing Festival Berlin gehen. Aber was sind sonst noch so Anlaufstellen, wo ihr sagt, okay, da kann man hingehen, wenn man sich jetzt anfangen möchte, für dieses Thema zu interessieren?
Man kann natürlich ins Technikmuseum hier in Berlin gehen, da ist aber auch sehr viel hinter Glas und läuft nicht. Man kann in andere Computermuseen gehen. Es gibt das Computerspiele-Museum hier in Berlin. Es gibt das Heinz-Nixdorf-Forum in Paderborn. Es gibt auch relativ kurz noch das Oldenburger Computermuseum. Da kann man auch sehr viel ausprobieren. Da sind sehr viele Rechner, die laufen. Man kann in die Afra kommen zum Vintage-Abend jeden Donnerstag.
Wo ist die?
In Lichtenberg in der Herzbergstraße 55, afra-berlin.de.
Alles klar. Haben wir jetzt noch etwas Wichtiges vergessen zum Thema Vintage Computing? Dinge, die ihr noch unbedingt sagen wollt, die ich nicht gefragt habe? Gut, ich nehme das dann mal als Nein. Was ist euer nächstes Projekt?
Ich habe noch ganz viele alte SGI-Hardware rumstehen, die ich noch nicht mal gebootet habe. Da müsste ich mal mit rumspielen. Und ich habe auch ganz neu eine Microwax bekommen, die habe ich aus Stuttgart so etappenweise nach Berlin geschleppt.
SGI, das war diese Grafikrechnung, wo früher sozusagen die ganzen Special Effects drauf berechnet wurden?
Ja, genau.
Ich habe mal mit einem Fernsehsender gearbeitet, da stand ein so ein Ding rum und das war wie Goldstaub. Sowas hast du jetzt mehrfach zu Hause?
Ja, davon habe ich einiges. Es wird auch SGI Indies mit so einer Indie-Cam zu sehen geben, womit man dann Webchat machen kann, wie in den 90er Jahren.
Großartig. Dexter, was ist dein nächstes Projekt?
Naja, also ich habe einen Xerox 820, den gibt es auch auf dem VCFB zu sehen. Der müsste mal ein bisschen restauriert werden, dass ich floppies Gepäck habe. Möglicherweise mache ich das als nächstes. Und dann habe ich noch so einen Robotronencomputer im Keller. Naja, der ist auch schon, ja der ist ja restaurationsbedürftig, wie das heißt.
Das wollte ich auch noch fragen. Vielleicht könnt ihr das noch ganz kurz sagen. Ihr habt am Anfang gesagt, Home Computer ist sozusagen eine Säule in diesem Vintage Computing. Es gibt aber einen krassen Unterschied zwischen Ost und West. Sind das einfach nur verschiedene Produkte oder gibt es auch sozusagen im Ansatz des Computerns verschiedene Produkte?
Naja, also ich habe den Unterschied sehr deutlich gemerkt, als ich diesen Robotronencomputer mir angesehen habe. Weil das ist ein sehr professionelles Gerät, das ist so ein Bürocomputer A5120 oder so etwas. Wenn man den sich ansieht, dann sieht man eigentlich eine sehr solide, verarbeitete, hochwertige Workstation. Also das ist wirklich ein sehr gutes Gerät, das ist ja auch da für die Industrie gewesen. Also das ist wirklich gut. Allerdings, wenn man sich dann anguckt, in welchem Jahr dieser Rechner gebaut worden ist und was für Fertigungstechnologien, also wie die Platinen aussehen und so, da drin verwendet worden ist, dann sieht man schon diese, ich weiß nicht, wie sie es damals genannt haben, Technologie-Lücke oder so. Also diesen Technologie-Rückstand, den sieht man da sehr deutlich. Das ist sehr interessant gewesen.
Also die waren sozusagen schon von Anfang an Vintage, die Computer.
Na ja, so schlimm ist wahrscheinlich nicht, aber du hast natürlich das sehr häufig gehabt, dass du quasi Nachbauten von Festmodellen hattest und alleine dadurch hast du eine gewisse Verzögerung. Das betrifft jetzt natürlich nicht unbedingt die Fertigung, aber das betrifft auf jeden Fall die Technologie an sich.
Ja, das war zum Beispiel so, dass in diesem Aussatzcomputer ist ja eigentlich ein Z80 drin, aber das war ein nachgemachter Z80, da heißt da irgendwie U880. Ist glaube ich eine 1 zu 1 Kopie, kann man durch ein Z80 ersetzen.
Okay, so, dann sind wir jetzt am Ende gekommen. Ich sage schon mal vielen Dank an Zeltophil und Dexter fürs Vintage Computen. Dannimo in seiner Eigenschaft als Abgesandter des Chaos Computer Clubs hat außerdem noch ein paar Verkündigungen zu machen am Ende. Meine Damen und Herren, Sie sehen bestens vorbereitet, Herrn Dannimo aus dem Chaos Computer Club.
Also mein Laptop ist mir soeben gestorben, aber ich habe hier noch kompetentes manuelles Backup im Formen des Moderators.
Im Formen des Moderators. Du wolltest zum Beispiel was zum Netzpolitik-Jubiläum erzählen. Aha, wolltest du möglicherweise sagen, dass es ein 10-jähriges Jubiläum gibt, das Blogs netzpolitik.org, dass Sie dazu am 17. Oktober in der Kulturboererei Berlin einen kleinen Kongress machen?
So ist das.
Hast du gut gemacht. Dann soll es ein Hackover in Hannover geben. Was ist das? Von 24. bis 26. Oktober, was ist ein Hackover?
Eines der vielen Veranstaltungen aus dem Chaos-Umfeld. Eines der vielen Veranstaltungen aus dem Chaos-Umfeld vom 24. bis zum 26.10.
Was heißt Veranstaltung?
Das ist ein, wie will man das am besten sagen, wer kennt den Kongress? So ungefähr kann man sich das vorstellen.
Liebe Leute von dem Radio, falls ihr euch fragt, was das bedeutet, das bedeutet, da kommen Leute zusammen, halten Vorträge, basteln und sitzen zusammen und quatschen.
Genau und die letzte Verkündigung, die ich habe, ist, dass die Meta-Rhein-Wein-Chaos-Days vorbei sind. Das ist ebenso eine Veranstaltung, wie die vorher genannte. Allerdings, hier kann man sich das Ganze mal anschauen. Auf media.ccc.de gibt es nämlich die Aufzeichnungen dazu.
Okay, jetzt könnt ihr das alte angucken. Wenn euch das gefallen hat, könnt ihr dann zu einem neuen hinfahren. Sehr schön, dann vielen Dank auch dir und vielen Dank dem Chaos Computer Club für's hier dabei sein. Nach uns, nach dem Chaos Radio, kommt Flo Heiler mit dem Night Flight und wird euch mit Gitarrenmusik bewerfen, wenn ich richtig informiert bin. Ich verabschiede mich an dieser Stelle. Mein Name ist Marcus Richter und ich habe noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschüsselt immer schön eure Backups.